Easy.
None.
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Welcome to Pokemon Smash or Pass.
I got myself two experts on the smashability...
Okay.
...of random characters.
I mean, I know you two have done a lot of Smash or Pass lists, right?
I've seen Bao done a couple of ones in her day.
And Snuffy, you definitely have done a couple of ones.
I've been cooking the next one for Monster Hunter Wild.
You caught me.
So, you can see on my stream, Bao and Snuffy are on the opposite side of me.
So, it's more like, you know, if I pass on something...
And if they smash, I need them to convince me why.
Why it's smashable.
You're just not seeing the vision.
Well, if you convince me, maybe I will see the vision.
This is such a great one to start chat.
Look at this.
I like that we're here to, like, brainwash her.
So, this is all randomized Pokemon.
So, it could be any one of them.
I don't know how long we're gonna go, honestly, until, I guess, until I start smashing all of them.
Until I just give up and be like, smash, smash, smash.
We gotta find her sleeper agent code for when she'll just start being like, suddenly, I think I'm gonna smash the ball.
I really wanna know what kind of Pokemon would, like, get you to smash without our help.
Wait, I get it now.
I see the vision.
Something will just click and you'll be like, it all makes sense.
Oh my god, everything just clicks.
She's gonna walk out of here like a different person.
They need one of those whole, like, free-to-use brain expansion, like, medical...
You see the pulsing, the brain, when you're like, whoa.
Oh my god.
Right here, you can see when she starts...
I get it now.
When she starts to understand.
Brain blast.
Her neurons be firing and stuff.
Maybe we'll know.
We'll get, like, a feeling.
We'll have to, like, pull it out of her.
Alright, okay.
Alright, so...
What's how you pronounce it?
Sogalio?
The lion, the god Pokemon from Pokemon Moon?
And Sun?
That was a 50-50?
Pokemon Sun.
I mean, like...
We looked up the height of him.
And it was, like, what?
Not that height matters, chat.
Not that height matters.
I mean, what if it's tiny?
Like, how do you...
It can vary, you know?
So, 11 feet?
On average?
11 feet.
That's, like, taller than the actual lion, right?
He weighs 500 pounds.
Holy fuck.
The average height of a lion.
The average height of a lion is actually 3 feet tall.
Oh, so he's, like, 2 lions then.
Wait, but he's not, like, steel-type.
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
He's 11 feet, so...
Sorry, my map's not working, so he's, like, 3 to 4 lions tall.
3 to 4 lions tall?
Is he?
I thought he was 3 feet tall.
No, he's...
No, he's 3 meters.
Oh!
Aware.
I was like, that's a fucking tiny lion if he's only...
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's, like...
Okay, well...
Has she ever seen a meter stick?
That's usually taller than, like...
That's, like, as tall as you are.
No, a meter's... Oh, wait.
A meter's, like, 60 inches.
Wait, how do you know that, like, on the top of your head?
It's 12 feet.
Wait, I don't know, 6 feet?
Okay, it's 3 feet, but 500 pounds.
No way!
Oh my god, that's a heavy lion.
He's steel-type, so it makes sense.
He's probably not gonna lay on you, so, like, if that's, like, a scary thing, I don't think he's gonna, like, full-body press, you know?
Damn.
We're just talking about this straight out the gate, huh?
Okay.
I didn't know I did that!
I was like, okay.
Logistically, I mean, he's not gonna kill you.
He's gonna, you know, be on top of you logistically.
Would you chat for a million dollars?
Would you?
I'm just saying, like, can I die?
What about that?
Okay, what if the stipulations were that no one would know, and you get a million dollars?
Would you do it?
Okay, but, like, that.
And whatever, like, injuries you have, like, the hospital can fix it.
Like, you can be completely cured.
Can they really fix that?
You just have to, like, infer it.
He's 11 meters tall!
He's 11 feet tall!
But you get a million dollars out of it, and nobody knows.
It's like nothing even happened.
I think the doctors will know what happened.
I think the doctors would know, but that would be breaking HIPAA.
The doctors would know, but that would be breaking HIPAA.
I don't know if they put that out anywhere.
What if they tell their therapist?
Have a comparison image?
How about this?
I feel like this is something they would tell their therapist.
Who would win?
Three to four lines.
I'm gonna be honest.
I kinda hate that he kinda looks like a motorcycle or something.
He looks like he's made of car parts, and I don't really think that's very attractive.
That's also what I think about.
I look at his feet, and they kinda look like...
They have...
Yeah, hockey pucks!
Wait, I see it.
It's just kinda goofy.
I don't even know what those are.
They look like metallic parts on him.
Like around his legs.
He looks kinda like a Gundam.
Oh, that's true.
I see that.
And then he has an avocado for a tail.
One thing that those...
Like the robo furries have, the proto...
What are they called?
The proto something?
The proto what?
It's like, have you ever seen those furries that have the robot faces?
And they've got like LED eyes?
He's got that!
Protogen is what chat says.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He also looks like a zoid, too.
Looks like a...
I have no idea what that is.
Oh my God, I had this guy!
Yeah!
I freaking had this.
Okay, for me it's a pass.
I feel like I die.
He's kinda like...
Goofy.
Alright, so...
Why were you guys trying to convince me you were all gonna pass anyway?
This was your first pass.
This is funny!
Okay, why are you guys passing?
I feel like I just die.
It's not Arcanine, so...
It's not Arcanine!
I get it.
He just looks kinda goofy.
I'm not a huge fan of the design.
It's like the guy you shouldn't worry about.
He's dorkier than like...
There's a better Pokemon in his demographic here.
That's true.
You have too much toys and fake parts, dude.
I need flesh and blood.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bro looks like he needs to be assembled.
It comes like in a package.
Why don't you go to your mom and put yourself back together?
You gotta get like...
AAA batteries.
Like batteries not included.
Alright.
Pass.
Alright, Latias.
Smash.
Smash, yes.
Did you see the movie, Doki?
As soon as Bow was like, instant smash on Latias, she's seen the movie.
Yeah, no, I've seen like...
Didn't Ash like kiss this Pokemon?
Yes.
Map me up, Ash.
Map me up.
Me too.
She can, I will agree.
She can shapeshift, right?
To any form you want.
So it's like, she's basically like a shapeshifter.
Like if you don't...
But like, are you smashing that form or...
What form though?
Whatever she wants to be that day.
She is...
She's a nice woman.
She's like kind and loving.
She's the perfect girl.
Wait, she has a child?
Wait.
Who's the father?
Someone said she has a child.
You're right, I will agree.
She is a better ditto.
Wait, this is real, I don't know this.
Oh my god!
We're siblings?
Anyway.
I've never seen that movie.
I didn't realize they ate more.
Um, I mean...
Look, they're an endangered species.
There's two of their kind.
And, you know...
They have babies!
I didn't even know that was how we get purebred like...
Dogs and stuff.
Oh my god, she's a Labrador!
She's a Labrador.
I mean, she's gotta save the bloodline.
Oh my god.
So, one million dollars and nobody would...
It's to save a bloodline, Doki.
Yeah, it's to save a bloodline.
And no one would know.
I'll agree.
Yeah, we get rid of all the DNA reports.
Like, we forge them all.
I would say...
There's only two of its kind!
Well, what about the lion?
There was only one of his kind!
We didn't even pass on him!
Yeah, but he was like an LED.
That's what I'm saying.
We can build another one of his.
Okay, I'll say...
Because...
Because she is...
She can shapeshift.
I will smash.
You know the girl version of her?
This is her.
No, no.
Oh, like what she looks like.
Okay, okay.
Me too, Ash.
She can give you upbeats.
She is!
Okay, she's pretty cute.
He's like chasing her around the city.
It was so cinematic.
I remember it to this day.
What does her child look like?
What do her children look like?
What if they're Ash's kids?
I don't know what Pokemon Heroes is.
That came out...
Oh, it says 2002.
Wait, what the fuck?
It is implied.
Since it was after her kiss with Ash, it was Ash's child.
Her brother had died prior to that.
The brother, Latios, died?
Yeah, Latios...
Well...
Wait, I don't even remember her flying away with kids at the end of that movie.
That's crazy.
I saw this movie like 20 bajillion years ago.
What?
I don't remember that at all.
So like, is that how Pokemon eggs are made?
They just kiss each other and then an egg pops out?
I think it's like Pokemon lore that nobody knows how eggs are made.
Oh, nobody knows.
It's like Latios takes his hair or something and then it closes it.
It's like fish, you know?
It's like any bodily fluid or parts works.
I mean, think about the plant Pokemon.
Yeah, it's like...
I don't know.
Like...
In Diamond and Pearl, if you go to the library in Jubilife City or something, I can't remember, but you go there and there's a book that talks about how Pokemon and humans used to like...
Yeah, they used to get married with each other.
Yeah, and then there's like that Typhlosion thing that...
Oh my god, that's right!
I literally memory hold that.
Oh my god, no.
I think I fell asleep yesterday thinking about that slacking one or whatever.
Oh no!
I don't want to think about it anymore!
Wait, what's the slacking one?
I just know about the Typhlosion one.
Oh my god, you haven't read the other stories?
After reading Typhlosion, I was like...
I literally buried that so deep in my mind.
I even remember tweeting about it.
Wait, what's the slacking one?
What did the slacking do?
They were all like...
Okay, you know like Disney princesses?
They all come from old fairy tales, but then if you read the true original fairy tale, it's like something really freaked up and horrific.
It's like that.
And there's...
Lots of...
It's pretty graphic.
Is it worse than the Typhlosion one?
Did you kidnap her or something?
The Typhlosion was like kidnapping, but she was like, it's okay, I'll live with you.
Yeah, and then they had like a hybrid.
It has like...
I think like...
I don't...
I don't know how to put it.
Hmm...
Like replace some words with like...
Okay, so slacking...
Yeah?
Take your time.
Slacking...
I'm really grabbing for straws here at the word.
So slacking...
Inconsiderately did some...
Oh...
Inconsiderately.
So inconsiderate.
You look very inconsiderate in this story.
Rude.
Wait, slacking is like...
It's the gorilla one, right?
I think it's like a gorilla sloth.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that the final...
That's the final evolution one, right?
The one that looks like Donkey Kong?
The giant one.
The one that is asleep all the time.
Alright, okay.
Anyway, let's not smash.
Let's go, that was easy.
Alright.
Mianfu.
And he's like...
It's cute.
I don't know if I want to smash that.
Oh my God, I found it.
Okay, I found the story.
I forgot how it was even started.
It's so bad.
Okay, the story starts by this little kid going around the forest or something...
and she like...
I think this one...
There was like Slakoth, the baby one.
Yeah.
And they...
One of them was like injured or something.
Oh yeah, okay, here we go.
Every day they were bored, the humans were bored.
So they would often catch Slakoth living in a nearby forest.
They would play cruel games with the captured Slakoth.
And sometimes killing them for fun.
Gouging out their eyes and cutting off their ears.
What the fuck?
And then eventually they come back and they start like killing all the humans and doing stuff to them.
Because they were like...
Remember?
Remember how you used to kill us?
Well, we're gonna kill you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think the craziest part is just the fact that...
They wrote all these stories, but they never...
They like...
Just for fun.
It was never published out.
It was just...
I don't know how this was even like never scrubbed.
Why was this just like on company computers?
Yeah, like on a company computer.
They're just like, let's just write some stories.
It's my bedtime story.
I love to read it every night.
It really does read like an ancient folklore though.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the reality of the ones that like...
Ancient civilizations have.
Yeah, yeah.
Like the world build, the Pokemon world.
But then like...
But it's like...
It never feels like it influenced the world itself.
Like...
Yeah, so what does this mean?
How does this change the trout population?
What is this, like a weasel?
Oh, this one, Mianfu?
Isn't he like...
A child?
Isn't this a child?
Isn't that a child?
It evolves at level 50.
Oh, okay.
So this is the final evolution of something.
No, no.
It starts to evolve at level 50.
So it's only got one evolution.
But it's not for 50 levels.
Which is really insane.
Okay, so he could be level 30.
And it'd be fine.
Well, it depends on how you see that.
It's like...
Do you see level where there's a baby Pokemon evolution?
Or do you see level based on age or experience?
Yeah, I'm like...
Is levels considered age?
Or like...
Just you look at them and it was like...
He looks like he's like...
He looks like he's just starting.
This is a weasel, Doki.
It's a weasel, Doki.
It's a weasel.
It's a fictional weasel.
It evolves at level 50.
Smash your butt.
It's only 1.5 meters.
1.5 meters.
Okay, okay.
It's two feet tall.
Wait, he's not that tiny.
I would pass.
It's just kind of meh to me.
I kind of want to squeeze it like a stress toy.
It kind of looks like it's meant to be gripped like that.
It's kind of cheap.
Like a proper chicken?
Kind of phallic, so maybe like...
I was gonna say kind of like a...
I mean, it does have the balls down there.
Yeah, it's got like that conal shape.
He has the...
The shape.
I would pass, though.
Yeah, I'd pass.
Alright, pass.
Oh, it's so rude.
He looks wild.
He looks like...
Oh my god.
The mask in Legend of Zelda.
What the heck is it called again?
The...
The magnamious...
What the hell is a mask called?
Majora!
Oh, Majora!
Magnamious mask.
It sounds like Ignoramus.
You goddamn magnamious.
I'm gonna pass.
This thing looks like it would kill me.
Yeah, I pass.
I pass.
Oh, no!
No, you're such a little guy!
No!
You're such a cute little guy!
My face!
It's like if he whips it out and it's like a...
Like a Subway...
No!
It's like...
Don't take away my whimsy!
What if they stack on top of each other?
One pulls it out and one's like on top and then they're like...
What?
Like a Lego?
Is that like a Lego?
Yeah, because the Darumaka are always like on top of each other.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
The lore.
Alright.
I pass.
Okay, wait.
Are you pass or smash?
Does it count as smashing if I debated like putting it up my butt?
No!
The hole is a hole.
Yeah, but it's like not the right hole.
Wow, what a beautiful day.
Jack, where did all my Darumakas go?
Wait, did you have anything to give me?
You have multiple.
Where'd they go?
Hey, everybody.
Why can't you sit down, Snuffy?
Take a seat.
Sorry about those Darumaka, Bao.
All good.
You can keep them.
Yippee!
Oh.
Hey, Snuffy's your favorite.
Well, it's your second favorite.
Puppy.
Yeah, I can't look at him like that.
He's just a puppy.
Yeah, he's just a good boy.
I just want to give him like scrunchies on his face.
He's just...
What?
You befriend him to get closer to the dad.
He'll be like, I'm gonna be your new mommy.
Yeah, he'd be such a good boy.
Let's make some...
Let's make some new...
Give you a step-brother.
Oh my god.
Let's give you a half-brother.
A whole littering thing.
I was gonna say.
Oh my god, sorry.
Puppies for sale.
Let's start a puppy mill.
That was my naming call.
It's time to...
Make some labradoodles.
What?
Alright, pass.
Among us.
How?
Among us?
Like...
I mean...
It's a mushroom.
I don't know what I'm...
What do you do with it?
If I was a guy?
Okay, I was gonna say.
If I was a guy, then I'd say smash.
Because like, that's one thing I could use.
That's like a pipe cleaner in length, Okie.
What are you saying?
No, it has a mouth.
Right there.
Look how small the little hole is.
That's like a spaghetti noodle.
You don't know, it could stretch.
You pencil-dicking that thing?
It's a mushroom.
My name is Skinny Penis.
Yes, girls.
Give me slay.
Oh my god, are you judging?
Are you judging?
I still think this looks like...
It just...
Well, it's a mushroom, right?
Okay, how inhumane it is if I cut the whole thing?
You know, it looks like...
You know...
It should go up your butt.
How?
Wait, how big is this?
I don't know if I should say it.
I'm just feeling the waters out right now.
Okay, but like...
How big is this?
Okay, right.
Yes.
Let's get the details.
Amoongus.
It's two feet.
Wait, that's a pretty big mushroom.
It doesn't say like width though.
That's true.
You gotta know the width of the...
It does weigh 23 pounds, so about...
Maybe like a heavier pound.
I don't know.
Rather light, honestly.
And then you can grow the mushroom.
You can like cut one...
Wait, maybe like the limbs grow back, right?
So you cut one of the mushrooms.
You can like grow it after like a post thing.
Like, you know, if you're hungry.
I'm trying to see if it says anything about getting its arms cut off.
Yeah, any fun facts?
It's actually highly poisonous.
Oh.
It lures prey close by dancing and waving its arms.
So I guess it...
It shows that like Pokeballs...
And it's like, ooh, Pokeballs.
I feel like it's more of a threatening thing.
Well, it lures Pokemon, I guess.
I don't know.
What is prey?
Does it eat Pokemon?
What does that mean?
It lures prey close.
I guess it lures a bug Pokemon?
Maybe they like...
Fungusify the Pokemon.
Oh, true.
So it's like the Parsec.
It's like the crab ones, too.
Who called it a biodegradable plug?
Oh my God.
What?
Biodegradable?
What does that even mean?
If I leave it in my ass long enough, it'll just like decompose, bro?
What did it get?
Moldy?
Moldy in your ass?
You'll probably grow more mushrooms.
You become part of the mushroom.
Like it starts controlling you.
A fungus colony.
Like a suppository.
Oh my God.
I feel like I already need to sit down and have a deep thought.
Boofing up fungus so your body can become a fungus colony.
That's really how we...
It's just like last of us.
Oh my God.
Stuffy's gonna be patient zero.
She's just putting random things up her ass.
She's just sewing with you.
She just puts random stuff up her ass.
There's no cure.
Nothing can satisfy her.
You know how Pokemon's slogan is like, gotta catch them all?
I don't know.
Dude, this is just gonna be like...
You know that episode of Pokemon where like Tentacruel starts attacking the city and taking over people?
Oh my God.
I saw one like that too from like a later series.
But it was like the same thing but instead of Tentacruel it was like...
Oh, Malamar I think it's name is.
Which is a really...
So there's this Pokemon called Malamar.
Wait, I think it's Malamar.
Or is that a rock?
Yeah, Malamar.
And it's like this tentacle one.
Let me post a picture for you guys.
And like it's really scary because like the lore of it says it's like...
Oh, the giant squid.
Yeah, it's like an alien.
And they're smarter than humanity.
And like they're actually super evil.
And in the anime they start mind controlling people to do their bidding.
What?
Just like in Baldur's Gate.
Yes, it's literally Baldur's Gate.
Oh my god.
It was kinda hard.
Just like in Baldur's Gate when you smash the octopus man.
I get it.
Alright, for me it's a pass.
I just don't know about Snuffy though.
I can't tell.
I'm kinda curious.
I sold myself on this.
You wanna smash?
Okay, me I'm pass.
What about you, Bal?
I don't know.
If I boofed it and I could experience like eternal euphoria due to like the hallucination of it's spores then yeah, sure.
Why the hell not?
You didn't even think about that.
You know I'm like a permanent ayahuasca in your ass.
Like a permanent trip or something?
Alright, you know what?
This might be better than reality.
This is a positive story.
It's like an on and off.
You just like pull it out and you're fine.
And then you put it back in and you're like colors of all sorts.
Exactly.
I'm passing.
Oh, a swan.
That's just straight up a chicken.
That's just a duck.
It's also like holding it's arms on it's hips accusatorily.
Aren't ducks like scary as fuck?
Yeah, they eat people.
Once they get a taste of human flesh they crave it.
They also are like really aggressive too.
They actually attack people.
Is this a caring swan?
Hmm, okay.
So it says swans start to dance at dusk.
The one dancing in the middle is the leader of the flock and it administers sharp, powerful pecks with it's billet.
Okay, that doesn't sound hot.
To deliver forceful, repeated strikes.
And then...
I think it's just like they move in packs and they're very elegant.
I feel like they just be really aggressive in general though.
I don't think it'd be a fun time.
I kind of love how they have like bras on it.
Yeah!
It looks like a little...
Like a little cleavage showing there.
The only look, no touchy.
Don't touch the goods.
Alright, I'm passing though.
I don't want to get involved with this.
I'm gonna pass.
There's just better fish in the sea.
There's just better...
Yeah, better birds out there.
Alright, Snuffy.
What about you?
I'll...
I'll pass.
Pass.
That was so quick.
Snuffy, please don't debate on this.
This is a challenge.
I want to know.
I just want to know.
What the third degree burns on your wrist you will feel like?
What if there's flesh inside those rocks?
Like a shell, you know?
What if it's actually cooling in there?
It's red.
It's glowing red, Snuffy.
What's at the top of it?
I don't think it's...
He looks ready and raring to go.
Where would you stick it?
Stick...
It's too wide here.
It says he's part of a mineral group.
Oh, if you're low on magnesium, this might be the guy for you.
Yeah, you can suck on the coal.
Anemia.
You know how some people make rock soup and stuff?
Yeah, the iron soup.
It says it forms coal inside of its body.
Coal dropped by this Pokemon once helped fuel fires of the people of the region.
By rapidly rolling its legs, it can travel over 18 miles per hour.
The temperature of the flames it breathes exceeds 1,800 degrees Fahrenheit.
The temperature inside its body increases when it experiences strong emotions.
It rolls around frantically while spewing flames.
It produces renewable energy.
It shits out renewable energy.
I mean, it'd be a perfect...
Dude, it gets faster and hotter when it's excited.
That's awesome.
That's awesome for you, Stephanie.
Maybe we do have a lot more in common than I thought.
Man, I'm gonna have to say it.
I think, yeah, I just don't think there's any fucking it if it's 1,800 Fahrenheit.
That's just unfortunate.
I'd be screaming in pain before it even gets close to me.
Maybe I could just rub my toes on it for one of those, like, hot coal baths or something.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, yeah.
You put him in the water.
Yeah, you put, like, water in it.
More than that, so I'll have to pass.
Then he'll die.
Pass.
Oh, crap.
What even is this?
It's, like, this gigantic Maxwell's the giant gorilla, but he's you know, he brings the band over I guess.
He brings the entire band.
What's happening?
What am I looking at?
Like, where does the Pokemon start?
He's right here.
This is his, like, garage band set up.
So he's right here.
Right here.
That's him right there.
I'm gonna say pass.
Like, I don't want him to, like, play on his garage band set up while, like, you know, stuff is happening.
Right.
Like, at that point, he's distracted.
He's not.
I don't like how he has, like, extra arms that are, like, tree branches.
That sounds... That sounds ouch.
Wrapping around you is, like, thumbs up, but then, like, with the, like, splinters.
Okay, here's Wonderwall.
Here's Wonderwall before we begin.
Here's Wonderwall.
Someone's, like, you know he can do it on the rhythm.
Thumbs up.
Oh, my God.
I can't.
He's so romantic.
Wow.
Pass.
I'm a pass.
Unless he wants me to squirt on the drum.
Saw's Book Spring.
Oh, yeah.
This guy only comes out in the spring.
Oh.
What does that mean?
I don't know anymore, Snuffy.
What does it mean, Snuffy?
I don't know what it means anymore.
Spring season, like, you know, salmon.
Care to elaborate?
Well, they beat their heads repeatedly against a rock when they... So he'll just be distracted.
Let's see what the Pokdex has to say.
They migrate according to the seasons.
People can tell the season by looking at its horns.
The plants grow on its horns change according to the season, yet they migrate, blah, blah, blah.
It seems that Saw's Book has many flowers on its ancestors will grow at a slightly slower pace because the flowers absorb the Pokmon's nutrients?
What?
The flowers are actually, it's like a body.
Okay, that's like his flesh, I guess.
So this is like a fungus situation.
Yeah.
Oh god, it says there are many Saw's Book enthusiasts.
The darker the red of the foliage that hangs from its antlers, the more stylish the Saw's Book is thought to be.
So he has like his own personal fan group, I guess.
Why did the Pokdex specify that like, just period, just like it has enthusiasts?
Period.
People really, really, really like Saw's Book, I guess.
It's pretty.
I say pass.
It's not...
I don't know.
It's just a deer.
Yeah, it's just a deer.
With parasitic flowers, yeah.
Alright, pass.
Yeah.
Smash.
Did we have residual thoughts of the last Pokmon?
I'm so curious.
Yeah, okay, well, I was just like...
You know what?
Actually, maybe.
I can't!
It can be anything you want it to be.
So like...
Are we smashing that or like whatever he transforms?
I'm just loyal to Suicune, so like anything similar to Suicune, I just feel like I'm cheating on Suicune.
Okay, you can turn it into anything.
I'd say smash, then.
Oh, are you snuffy?
It can transform into anything.
When it transforms, it changes into a stone to avoid being attacked.
It doesn't have to just be Pokmon, so that's like definitely a candidate.
Yeah, yeah, no, there's like an episode where he transforms into like a person.
Oh, you know this one.
Yeah, because the face is like a ditto.
It depends on how good the ditto is.
There's like dittos that are like massive.
How good are you?
Okay, you know like there's like this Okay, have you guys ever heard about this Pokmon manga where it's like it's super hardcore, like Pokmon Red or some shit.
I don't remember what it's actually.
Yeah, and then like, you know, yeah, and it shows like decapitated Pokmon and eating Pokmon and stuff like that.
And then there was one of the storylines where like the ditto actually transforms into a Pokmon trainer and he's like evil or whatever.
But he's like a really like high level ditto.
So you can't tell it's a ditto.
So like smash.
All I need is...
I'm gonna transform.
I'm gonna get a ditto.
Have it transform into Doki.
Do like a smash or pass stream of like all the Pokmon and smash every single one of them.
That is your entire goal.
Instead of trying to...
It doesn't talk though.
So yeah, Doki being like, would you smash this?
And Doki would just nod like...
I'll have the ditto hit like a pre-recorded like sound bites of Doki saying smash.
Oh yeah, I would smash.
Thank you, Doki.
They're all like spliced together words and stuff.
Alright, Torracat.
No, pass.
I would smash his father.
I was gonna say, I think like...
His father scares me.
His father is a little goofy and it took some time to grow on me, but I would smash his father.
I'm glad he's low.
Why don't you want to smash the dad?
He's a freak.
You don't even know him.
Have you met him?
He's a freak.
He gives uncomfortable vibes.
What is he gonna do?
Maybe after like four drinks.
Four drinks?
He would just hit your ass when you walk across him at the bar.
He would probably start crying about his ex-wife.
I have three kids.
I don't know why she left.
I just kept buying trading cards from cereal boxes, but she left me.
Pass.
What is that?
Do you guys know the lore on this guy?
He's all messed up.
I hate it.
I think it's really fucked up and it makes me uncomfortable.
Yeah, pass.
They're not even part of the same bodies.
Isn't it constantly in pain or some shit?
I feel like people talk about how messed up this is and how it's real and these Pokemon were created from messed up fossils being mismatched together.
Two things.
Why do we continue doing it and why do we not meet humanity any ramifications for this?
How can we not have repentance?
We got repented for creating false life.
At this point, why are we stopping this?
These evil corporations are bad.
But we can create fucked up Pokemon and that's okay.
How come after the flick off?
Because there's two versions of him, right?
There's one where it's the head.
There's five?
Yeah, there's a ton of them.
There's at least four, I think.
No, that's so sad.
I hate it here.
I thought it was just three because there's three distinct parts.
Oh my god.
They're like, maybe like the second attempt it'll be better.
And then they just fucked up every attempt.
They didn't get it right a single time.
I can't.
Someone said it's just like Full Metal Alchemist.
Goodbye.
But they do it four more times.
At least they have ramifications.
At least there's even like laws there.
There's no laws.
Are there Pokemon rights?
Wait, do Pokemon have rights?
No!
They're items.
I mean, they basically are.
If you put it in a Pokeball and leave it dusting on a shelf for 20 minutes.
Yeah, you put it in your computer and it's a data mine.
And mine me some Bitcoin Pokemon.
I took this thing from its family so I could just mine Bitcoin.
No, you know like once I got the digital Pokemon.
What was it, the Polly?
Digimon!
No, the Polly.
Porygon, Porygon, Porygon.
NFT bros are gonna mine for Porygon and catch like 100 Porygons, put it in my PC and mine me some Bitcoins right now.
They're gonna use Rotom as like a cursor mouse and it'll be like, please let me see the sun just this once.
Yeah, just turn your webcam on.
Rotom will be like the Fallout New Vegas Mr. House type thing in the future.
This is so sad.
I'm passing on this weird little freak.
Yeah, pass on this freak.
Put him down.
He went extinct for a reason.
Oh, Bulbasaur, pass.
Oh my God, chat said Team Rocket sells Porygons.
They do.
At the casino, they're literally selling you NFTs and shit.
They're literally selling NFTs.
They're selling like dragon...
What was it?
Oh my God, Dragonairs or whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they were selling them.
Yeah, dude, they're literally selling Porygons legally.
That's crazy.
Wait, someone was like, Team Plasma, try to give Pokemon rights and we stopped.
Wait, it's so true.
I played that entire game.
The guys are like, you fight them and they're like, we just want Pokemon to be treated like animals.
They should be left alone to the wild.
Be quiet, idiot.
How dare you think they deserve the same rights as us.
We need them to keep mining.
Wait, we send Pokemon into the mines too.
No.
We make all the Machop and like, exercise Pokemon, lift things and build buildings for us.
Like, we're so mean.
Yeah, why did we stop Team Plasma?
He just capitalized these creatures that just didn't ask to exist.
Wait, did you see that new...
Did you see like the... There's like a new trailer that it showed for the newest Pokemon game.
And the newest villain was like... Okay, I saw a screenshot for it.
I don't know if he's like the actual villain.
But like, there was a screenshot of the villain being like, apparently if you win the league or whatever, you get one special wish.
And then the...
Yeah, the guy was like, if I win, I'm gonna abolish all transportation so they're forced to use my taxi company.
That's awesome.
That's crazy.
I was like, that cat...
Is he a real villain?
Like, the taxi...
Dude, that's like catching a Jirachi and be like, I want a Dr. Pepper.
He could've just wished for a million dollars, but he's just gonna say like, I wanna work for the rest of my life.
Taxi driver for the rest of my life.
Yeah, final boss is capitalism.
I was like, holy fuck.
Okay.
And I'm like, wait, but then can't we just use Pokemon to fly?
Like, for transportation?
Yeah, that's what he's saying.
I think he's trying to capitalize it because he's like, no more free walking.
No more charge to travel now.
They can just wish for stuff like that?
Like, are they just forbidden to fly now?
Like, they just don't...
Like, I want my mom to die.
All forms of transportation is gone now.
What if somebody super twisted like that?
Like, what are the rules?
Is it like a Pokemon?
Are they just gonna like, delete them from existence?
Just control alt delete.
Oh god.
You know when they do like, release the Pokemon in my PC, do we just delete the data?
Oh my god.
Do we like, move the trash?
Like, where do they go?
Doesn't it say little text where it's just like, they have been released in the wild or something?
I swear when you say release it's like, Pokemon has been released in the wild.
Bye bye Pokemon!
It says something like that, I swear.
I swear!
Is that true?
I don't know.
Or do they go to the farm upstate?
You never existed.
Your data is just gone.
Forever.
Alright, Bulbasaur.
Pass.
What that mouth do, Bulbasaur?
I know he has like, vine whip, but like, that's a child.
Okay, so I have like a fixation with the mouth.
And I gotta say, every time I see a picture of like, a frog, you ever see the way they press their tongue against their mouth and stuff?
Or like, how they eat?
I'm just saying.
Wait, okay, send me a picture, so maybe I can see your vision.
You guys ever see the animations of all the stars being chopped up and turned into dishes?
Oh yeah, I have.
Yeah, the Chikorita one?
That one was so traumatic.
They like, peeled her like a banana.
Yeah, they peeled her like a banana!
Wait, what?
What are you talking about?
Oh, that's Goron, my comfort character.
That literally is.
Like, there's like a...
I wanna do this with Bulbasaur.
I'm scared.
I'm scared too.
What's your problem?
Wait...
You could...
There's Ivysaur, and then there's like...
What was the third one?
Venusaur.
Yeah, why would...
I mean...
Why Bulbasaur?
Why not Ivysaur?
They're covered in like, warts and like, overgrown weeds.
What about Ivysaur?
He's pretty cute.
I don't know.
He didn't look like he'd call me back, dude.
I think you're gonna get poison ivy.
And dry throat too.
I'm gonna be itching for days.
Bulbasaur, look how good he is, dude.
He's clean.
He's just a goofy little guy.
I'm passing.
But Stuffy will smash.
I will smash, you're right.
I will pass.
Alright.
Pass.
Alright, I'mma pass.
Stuffy, are you thinking?
Alright.
No, I don't like this guy.
Yeah, I don't think we need to explain ourselves.
He doesn't seem like he's having fun.
Have you ever played the GameCube games?
Uh, yeah.
Which ones?
The Shadow?
The Colosseum and XD Gale of Darkness.
I feel like those games made me specifically hate this whole line.
Oh yeah, me too.
I hate the guy.
The disco man.
Yeah, no, fuck that guy.
And then he always shows up everywhere you go.
None of that.
And there weren't many Pokemon in that game.
There was only like a hundred or so.
So it was like, this guy was just there.
No, my goat.
I'm sorry, chat.
I'm sorry.
I'm not fucking your goat.
I like Odicolo though.
I don't like the way he dances.
He freaks me out.
He's like, take that back.
I'm here to be a legend.
Oh yeah, what about the really freaking...
Oh my...
Okay, you know what?
Another good comparison here.
Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
I was just gonna say, he is so bad.
He is so bad.
Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
Do you remember the scene where Dusknoir arrests him and ties him up?
I don't know what happened to me.
But like, I just...
Something changed.
And Dusknoir is just like, I finally got you.
And you're just like, what's going on?
And then they just grab him and yank him.
And he's just like, you filthy traitor.
I...
I want him so bad.
It's insane.
He's such a cool character in Mystery Dungeon.
That game, yeah.
I wouldn't have probably said Smash if it wasn't for PMDD.
It's true.
He was really good in that game.
I would actually say Smash, yeah.
I want him to rest his hand on my hips.
I don't know what else to say.
Oh my god, his two fingers like clenched around your bones.
Yeah, please.
Please.
I cried playing that game.
Oh no, me too.
That game was so good.
I wish they re-released it, but like I know they re-released it in a 3D format, but I wish it was like the classic 2D pixel.
Yeah, yeah.
It doesn't have the same soul as mine.
I remember crying when I got to the ending, where you know, your partner was like, I'm going back to the human world now.
Goodbye, my...
God.
And I was like, no, I want to stay here with my Pokemon finder.
I can't, bro.
I can't.
Yeah, the first two games got me like a must.
Such a good story.
Okay, the unanimous must.
Pass.
Okay, well we were at peak, and I'm afraid that is very far.
It's like the Sahara Desert now.
Dear God.
He looks like a grandpa.
Like, he's like, I don't think...
He's like, go back to bed, sir.
I'll clean my ass after I'm done with it, dude.
Doesn't he have a wife?
Like, the other guy, the jealous female?
He just looks like the top of my head.
Oh, he looks like a Pringles mascot.
Someone was like, Mr. Pringles, sir.
Or like, cannot believe it.
You just took your head off.
This is literally...
Put it back on.
He's just a head.
What is he gonna do?
There's no mouth.
There's not even a mouth.
Okay, wait.
Let's get some...
The creepiest part about this Pokemon that you might not expect is that it's actually a ghost type Pokemon, right?
Oh, so he's a dead grandpa.
Hmm.
The Pokedex says, the fate of ships and the crew wander into Jellicent's habitat, all sunken, all lost, all vanished.
They propel themselves by expelling absorbed seawater from their bodies.
Their favorite food is life energy.
What does that even mean?
Its body is mostly seawater and it says that there's a castle of ships Jellicent have sunk on the sea floor.
Oh my god.
Oh my God.
Dude eats the souls of anyone who passes by him.
Yeah.
That's horrifying.
You laughed at him and he sunk like entire navies.
Someone was like, like a succubus?
He's literally a succubus.
There's a siren.
He's more like a siren.
Oh yeah, yeah.
The one that he calls the ships closer.
That's a hot part.
Yeah, just like Monopoly man siren.
He's got like the cartoony eyelashes, so maybe this is actually like a feminine depiction because that's how like people always determine like a feminine picture.
Yeah, but like what if instead of like, you might think that's like a mustache, but what if that's actually like, it's like big naturals.
The boobs, right?
It's like, it's a siren.
It's supposed to have legs wrapped around its face.
It might be a male but it's like, it's giving the depiction so you want to like go and squeeze.
Oh, it looks like thighs, right?
You want to squeeze the thighs.
How bad is it to be like in the ocean for that long that you look at a jellicent and be like Yeah, I mean It's perfectly round, like a boob, a butt, like cheeks.
Is that like a woman posing?
Is she holding her cheeks?
Is she masquerading?
Is it cloud stew?
You know like, how crazy are you feeling seven months into sea?
It's like narwhals, you know?
Remember when that's how mermaids were?
Or that's...
It's like, sailors wanted to sailors wanted to fuck narwhals.
And they invented the story of mermaids because they saw a narwhal and they're like, that's that's a hot woman right there.
Or was it manatees?
Have you ever seen a narwhal?
Sorry, I meant manatees.
They look the same to me.
Manatees?
Except one one has a horn.
I was like, what part of the human female has like a giant unicorn horn?
That would be right here, pants girl.
I mean, sailors wanted to fuck manatees.
So like, I guess like, a jealous set ain't so far off.
At least he has the thighs for it.
I'll still say pass.
I'm still gonna say pass.
I'm gonna smash.
Where would you smash?
No, no, how would you smash this?
Yeah, like on my nips.
Like a suction thing.
Wait, it kinda does.
Oh, okay.
You can see the vision.
You just see it and pass like, wait, I see it now.
I see it now.
It said it's mostly seawater, so like, I'm gonna just squirt it.
Oh my god.
Do you fill it with a different liquid, bro?
It must just simply feel like your life energy is being sucked out, so like...
That must explain it.
That's what they say about Vaporeon, why you're jealous and all white, dude?
Pass.
It's an ant.
Listen, I...
Yeah, this is an ant.
I'm sorry.
It's an ant.
It's not even a hot ant.
And it's made of metal.
Dude, imagine I encounter this in the forest.
Clank, clank, clank!
Bro, he's just gonna break the bed.
Pass.
Oh, it's your favorite!
There's Donkey!
That's me!
That's true!
He's got your hair!
Pass.
I would smash and nickname it Donkey Bird in my game.
I mean, he has a big mouth.
If I was a guy, I'd say smash.
What?
I don't need to be a guy to smash.
I mean, look at the mouth!
He's gonna feel nice and soft and treat me well.
He'll be cozy in the cold weather.
He looks like, you know, like...
If you gave a funny guy a chance and then he changes your life.
Look at him in the Pokemon room.
He looks like Seth Rogen.
Oh.
He's Seth Rogen.
That's a funny guy if you gave him a chance.
That's kind of what Seth Rogen gives, right?
Yeah, he looks like Seth Rogen.
Dude, you did his laugh really good!
Yeah, yeah!
I mean, he does look like him.
He actually...
He has his color palette, too.
His color scheme.
You weren't giving Seth Rogen color palette?
Yeah, I was giving Seth Rogen color vibes.
Wait, wait.
The Pokedex entry for Ludicolo says...
Ludicolo begins dancing as soon as it hears cheerful, festive music.
This Pokemon is said to appear when it hears the singing of children on hiking outings.
Upon hearing an upbeat and cheerful rhythm, the cells in Ludicolo's body become very energetic and active.
Even in battle, this Pokemon will exhibit an amazing amount of power.
Oh, he's strong.
He doesn't look like it, though.
Okay, so he's always gonna play music.
Get into the vibes.
So, like...
Wait, he has rhythm, then.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm still passing.
No, I think he would put on something tasteful.
Like the... a marachi band.
Yeah.
He'd put on, like, Redbone.
Redbone?
What's Redbone?
From Childish Gambino.
Oh.
I don't know how that sounds like, though.
It goes like...
Pass.
That's a fucking rat.
That's Snuffy, dude.
That's Snuffy.
Why would you smash him?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slow down here.
Wait, so you'd smash Rattata?
Yeah, about.
You can't smash...
You wouldn't smash Snuffy?
Like...
Well, there's one thing wrong with her.
That's her equivalent.
That thing is right there.
No, no, no.
The world was only Gen 1 Pokemon.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
I would be...
What's your house other than Rattata?
Pikachu.
Not even.
That's true.
But she's...
Yeah, but like, Pikachu is like a domesticated mouse.
Rattata is like a wild rat.
Yeah.
With rabies, I guess.
Yeah, with rabies.
Actually, then I would 100% pass.
Oh my god, Nidoran.
Oh my god, I could be a caked up Nidoran.
Aren't like, Nidoran's poisonous, though?
Like, they bite you and then you die?
You just have like...
You just have antidote on you every time.
Oh my god, like, what if like, it's at night and all you hear is like the poison damage sound effect?
God damn it, Bow.
It's like in the old Pokemon games where you take a step every time and you just...
Every movement you make...
Show off!
Get my boy out of here.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's just gonna be like what's mommy and daddy doing right now?
He literally has freckles.
He's a little baby.
This is my precious baby boy.
And then Squirtle's right after.
I can't.
Squirtle!
Squirtle, Squirtle.
The fire squad.
I wanna hold one in my arms each and give them kisses.
They're too sweet.
I kinda think Squirtle's hands were meant for my tits, but...
I'd let him feel.
I'm his mother.
Let him do biscuits.
Squirtle biscuits.
Yeah.
It'd be cold.
Flygon.
Smash.
For sure.
Wait, why?
Why?
I don't know.
Flygon is a good boy.
I can see it.
I get it.
I feel like Flygon has always been depicted as like a very cool and like...
I feel like there's one where he's wearing a scarf.
I can't remember which game, if it's like PMD again, but there's like a really cool one where he's like a scarf.
He's like a dragon.
It might be like mangas too.
The ones you're talking about.
They like kill people.
He's supposed to be like a dragonfly too.
I mean, he looks cool.
He has like the little goggles stuff going on.
He's cool, suave.
He has like gross bug eyes.
No, he doesn't.
That's just like his cover.
When he flies too fast.
It's like in Digimon.
The MC always has the cool epic anime goggles.
Yeah, exactly.
You know, licked back hair, he's so cool.
I bet the noise he'd make is crazy.
It'd be like...
Like a cicada.
He's like...
Vibrations, baby.
Yeah, he's like...
He flies really, really fast, so he has like a lot of vibrations going on.
Yeah.
What's the Pokdex say?
It's Trump, Trapinch, and then Vibrava.
Flagon whips up a sandstorm by its wings.
The wings create a series of notes that sound like singing.
Because the singing is the only thing that can be heard in the sandstorm.
This Pokmon is said to be the desert spirit.
A rude sandstorm.
That's how you know it's nearby.
Yeah, it sings.
Smash, smash.
You know what?
I can see it.
I'll say smash.
I can see it, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Pass.
Wait.
Look at him, though.
He's a rock!
What do you mean, look at him?
He looks like he would help carry your groceries to your car.
And lean against the dashboard and be like, Hey, what are you doing after this?
And then he'd take you to a nice dinner.
Because he's like, hey, well, I actually know a place.
Then he'd be like, oh, yeah.
And then he'd pretend to yawn and stretch his arms around you.
During the movies and whatever.
He's gonna make that face before he leans in.
Gives you a kiss.
I still think he looks like Harry Nutz.
Like with a mole on him.
But what about his personality, Stuffy?
There's nothing wrong with Harry Nutz.
I'm just saying that's what he looks like.
So what'd you smash?
I dig the hairstyle and the eyebrows a lot.
This is an upgrade from normal Geodude.
I would say this is an upgrade from normal Geodude.
Like this one is a Geodude with a personality.
Yeah, yeah.
The other one is a Geodude that looks like a gym bro.
He looks like he goes to raves.
But like, you know, he's just there for the vibes and the music.
What is this freaking Geodude?
What are you saying?
I'm looking at this guy who looks like he's like 60 and balding.
And you're like, yeah, he looks like he goes to raves.
And he would take really good care of you.
And he would carry your groceries.
He looks like a nice guy.
Who said Geodude with hair plugs?
Oh, he looks like he doesn't get up off the couch anymore.
And he just gave up on his dreams.
No, he's not.
Look at that determined face.
He knows what he's about.
Yeah, his life is just getting started.
He knows what he's worth.
I don't know, he's got wrinkles.
Where?
Like, look at his forehead.
He's got those like stressed old man wrinkle forehead things.
He's been through too much.
No, it's just a dent.
It's just a dent in his head.
What are you trying to say?
There's something wrong with having dents in your head?
I'm just saying he's been wearing too many headphones for too long.
He's been wearing them for too long.
You look just like him.
Alright, I didn't know you felt this way.
I'll take note.
Come on Tyler1, let's get out of here.
Hey, Tyler1.
Look, Tyler1.
He got a child and he has a girlfriend.
I think they're not married, right?
Yeah, he got a girlfriend.
He has a child.
Look, he made it.
Someday, Aloha Geodude's gonna find his perfect one.
Match.
Just like Tyler1.
I'm gonna be a stay at home mom.
He doesn't deserve you guys.
But I'm glad that you're there for him.
Yeah.
Okay, so Bao is clearly Smash.
I'm a pass.
What about you, Snuffy?
Did Bao convince you?
No.
I'm passing.
Me and Geodude are gonna go to the gym and take creatine together.
Goodbye.
Pass.
He doesn't even have eyes.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's evolve him into Golbat.
No, not Golbat.
Wasn't there like an evolution above Golbat?
What was his name?
Crowbat.
Wasn't Crowbat like, cooler?
No, no, no.
Yeah, he's cooler.
You're right.
But what is different about the two?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You think about Golbat and you're just like...
What lovely mouth you got, girl.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, with his tongue out too and everything, right?
Oh yeah, he's kinda freaky.
He's kinda freaky.
I'm gonna pass on Zubat, dude.
Yeah, no, Zubat, yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I think he would know some things in the bedroom, you know?
He looks like he's about to dive bomb into someone's bussy.
Okay, I'm gonna let you guys debate real quick.
I need to feed my dog.
I'll be right back.
No chat, that wasn't me.
Hello?
Anyways.
I just wanna know what Doki would think too.
Bird bias.
I wonder though.
Okay.
The only bird I would smash on sight is Decidueye.
Which one is...
Oh, that's Rowlet.
Decidueye's good.
I don't know why...
Oh, what's the one that I like?
He's red.
Fuck.
Bird Pokemon.
Bird Pokemon that's red?
Swallow?
Chat, on sight.
It would be on sight for me.
That's like the bird Pokemon on sight.
If I don't think like a legendary, like Articuno.
Moltres?
Talonflame?
He flies.
He's flying.
Chat, it's literally like a bird bird.
Like he's a big bird.
That must be from one of the new gen.
I'm not sure.
Nobody's got him.
Everybody's just saying Talonflame.
How could you forget the goat?
Wait, wait.
I don't trust chat.
They don't know anything.
I'm trying to tell them my favorite bird.
Bravery?
The American one?
Bravery.
Until the room stinks.
Till the walls start peeling.
I want my skin to have his Talon marks.
He looks like a griffin, so I understand.
Yeah.
He's all muscle, dude.
He's a behemoth on top.
For America.
The floors get water damage.
Oh my.
I want him to do that thing where birds like...
Do that thing in the sky where they start like...
You know.
They clasp their Talons together?
Yeah, they clasp their Talons and then they do...
And while they're spinning in the air and plummeting.
Okay, I didn't know about that part.
I knew it was like a courtship dance.
No, they're literally...
They're literally doing it and then...
They have to successfully finish.
There's actually reports of them dying that way.
Because they hit the ground before they finish.
Oh my god, it's like a fucking adrenaline rush.
This shit.
He's doing tricks on it.
I want to hear the Tony Hawk special trick noise.
It's like...
500 points.
And then you see like...
You know those tally scores going up on the top left.
It'd be like...
Every time you get a successful trick it's like...
500.
Wheelie.
And then there's like move names for every successful trick you do.
Successful wheelie.
Wheelie.
Oh my god.
Style points.
We gotta move to this guy.
My boy Halucha.
Because I could talk about bravery all day.
Pokedex says...
Short but sturdy.
He's using a special move and gets itself into a pinch.
Yeah, I don't think he's...
He's too busy flexing on him.
Yeah, he's too...
So it's like short king.
Short king.
I love Luchadors though.
They're so cool.
Then why don't you like Incineroar?
Yeah, why don't you like Incineroar?
What is he?
A freak.
He wishes he was as cool as Halucha.
That's like one of those WWE...
They were told to be the enemy.
To the crowd.
Nobody likes them.
Halucha is natty and Incineroar is not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
I'm gonna smash Halucha.
Just so I can say that I had it with a Luchador.
More of a wrestler.
Like a Luchador.
WWE Pokemon.
Got a little queso in me.
Pass.
What about you, Belle?
He kind of gives me the ick, so I'm gonna pass.
The ick.
Pass.
He's just too innocent.
It's like...
The innocence.
Yeah, I'd pass.
I'd pass.
The metronome would just blow us all up anyway.
Yeah, that's so true.
I'd feed him applesauce.
Applesauce.
It just looks like he would really like applesauce.
Pass.
I think some people would say smash, but I'd say pass.
Yeah, string about eight of those together and I'm smashing.
Yeah, I was thinking that.
I was like...
I was thinking about the Takumura or whatever.
And I was thinking about the fucking...
The little monkey guys.
And I was like...
If she wanted to stick those up her ass...
She's gonna want to stick a fucking electrode.
Dude, the neighborhood power's gonna go out.
Like, damn, what's going on tonight?
Where's my power?
And then it was just like...
Incinerated Snuffy.
And in the middle of the street...
Died what she loves doing.
Wait, Snuffy, are you muted?
She's just...
Thinking a little too hard about how her night would go.
She's just imagining the scenario.
Alright, tell us your dream scenario with Electrode.
Um...
Is this the first evolution?
No, it's the second one.
Oh my god.
Okay, can you imagine...
How do they level up?
Please tell me where the stone is based on.
It's like level 36 or something.
Dude, I'm just saying, string them together, like I said, okay?
Then they all evolve at the same time.
Midway through.
Oh my god.
They just gain XP.
Like, you know, okay, this is my idea.
You give all of them EXP share.
I can't.
Absolute cinema.
There's rare candies all around the room.
EXP share.
I'm frantically unwrapping the wrappers.
What do I do?
Shovel them up.
I can't.
Eat up my children.
You are the reason Team Plasma exists.
You are the reason why they exist.
You are a problem to Pokemon society.
We were never the heroes.
I feel like we just posed together.
It was like Team...
Team Plasma was right.
Team Plasma, yeah.
We got a sort of plasma.
Oh, brother.
It's your favorite guy.
It's your favorite guy, now he's bigger.
Do I read off if he's got anything that helps me out this time?
Upgrades.
Colossal.
Colossal?
Oh, your name is Colossal, huh?
Yeah, with a col.
He's 2.8 meters tall.
AKA 9 feet tall.
He's 685 pounds.
Almost 700 pounds.
He's gonna fucking kill you before anything happens.
He's peaceful.
He's usually peaceful.
Just don't vandalize the mines.
It doesn't matter.
He can just fucking step on you and your internal organs are gone.
If you invade its opponents, Colossal will vigorously shake its body, scattering coal from its smoldering back.
How'd you do that?
What was that?
That was my raccoon reflex.
You heard...
What part did you read that triggered it?
Something about the coal falling from his back.
Yeah, I was like, there's a coal falling from his back.
I want it to land on me and I'll be like, ow shit!
Instead of candle wax, it's just 900 degree coals.
Yeah, imagine the sparks.
I'm smashing.
Goodbye everybody.
I'm just gonna kiss my fingers.
See you later.
Peace out!
Die by doing what she loves.
Pass.
That's like...
There's nothing there.
You can use the ridges.
Oh, like a washing machine.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, I was curious.
Genuinely, I was like, I know I got a good mind for this sort of thing, and I can just say anything I wanted to.
But what is the thought here?
Is there an appeal here?
Pull up ye olde website.
Ye olde website of times and times.
There's not much.
Maybe...
Maybe ten?
Ten examples?
Awful.
Awful things.
I'm so curious.
What is it?
I think...
I think people just treat it pretty much...
Just like a...
Like a what?
I mean, it's an inappropriate word.
What?
What could be more inappropriate than what we've already said?
Oh, well...
I think people just use it as like an own-a-hole.
Oh...
Hmm...
Literally, it's just like from behind.
They just see like...
I don't even see anything.
It's just an orb.
Exactly.
But there's a hole there.
Yeah, there's another hole in the back.
There's another hole?
I thought there was one hole.
There's a hole behind it?
No!
I mean, there's two holes.
I guess if you're a guy, you'd say smash, yeah?
I'm gonna pass.
I'm passing on him.
I'm passing.
Salmon is awaiting, though.
I feel like using the ridges or its bodies is just more ethical.
Okay, oh.
Yeah, I think the...
Oh no, he seems really angry.
I don't know...
How do you stick anything near that?
He seems really mad.
I'll say pass.
I'll wait for his father.
Alright, Rhyhorn.
I know where Snuffy's gonna stand on this.
I know exactly what part she's looking at.
I don't.
You don't?
Wait, you don't?
What are you looking at?
What do you mean?
Go ahead.
What are you thinking?
Just tell me.
I can't see the vision.
Can you explain it?
I personally would say pass.
I was saying that I think Snuffy would say smash because...
What did Snuffy say?
I was just saying, you know, Rhyhorn and like...
What part is there from his name that's just there?
I guess.
I mean, he's a walkie-talkie.
That's uncool.
Flaming hot 9000 degrees.
What was it?
That's like making love to a Harley Davidson.
Is that really messed up, chat?
All you had to do was just like...
What was it called?
Get like a...
Get some sandpaper.
You're gonna rough that shit up.
I mean...
I was gonna say make the horn less spiky.
So...
You're gonna sand down your Pokemon horn so you can...
You're gonna...
I'm gonna sand down my horn so I can...
Relax.
It's like you're cutting it off.
I'm not like Team Rocket.
Like I'm gonna cut off the horn or something.
I'm not gonna cut it off, guys.
We're gonna smooth it down with like those smooth turners or whatever.
And then you like shape it too so that it's got ridges.
Just imagine falling into like a Pokemon battle with somebody and they're like, go Rhyhorn!
And you're like, dude, what's up with your Rhyhorn?
And it's ridged and sanded down and you're just like...
Dude, what's going on?
You know like...
You know those tumblers?
Like rock tumbling?
I'm gonna rock tumble my Rhyhorn down round.
Make him round.
Make him less round.
Jesus!
You might as well just like throw him into the ocean and let the ocean like...
Smooth him down.
Who would win?
One Rhyhorn or one rock tumbler?
We can polish it!
It'll be nice and shiny!
Yeah, just use rock polish on him like 500 times.
Why don't you just put like a...
I don't know, like a glove or something over it.
Like a cover.
You know like...
Those like coffee mug holders?
Get that, but like horn shaped.
Like a beard cover?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but like, you know, in whatever shape you want.
That's more ethical.
I want to put like a giant Hulk fist over his toe.
Hulk fist?
Okay.
If you wanted a Hulk fist, why don't you just give a Pokemon with a Hulk fist?
Like a Machamp.
Yeah, why don't you just...
Why are you trying to turn Rhyhorn into something that Rhyhorn isn't?
You're gonna hurt its feelings.
I'm sorry, Rhyhorn.
I guess it's not meant to be.
She's modding the Rhyhorn to her like...
To her wants.
I'm not modding to my wants.
I'm just giving the suggestion to Snuffy's wants.
I can't.
We keep putting this on me.
No.
What Snuffy wants.
Right, I forgot.
Look,
see, there's the Hulk fist for you, Snuffy.
There it is.
That's a balloon.
I mean, it's a softer version.
It's like...
I guess, yeah.
It'd be softer.
It's stretchier.
I pass.
Freak.
This is like...
I'm so confused.
Like the obvious furry bait Pokemon you pass, but like a literal...
Like a tub of coals.
I don't understand.
She just doesn't like goofy guys.
She doesn't like goofy guys.
She doesn't...
I like goofy guys.
Clearly not.
I think you guys are trying to say he's goofy, but I feel like he's giving like...
Freak.
This isn't goofy.
I wouldn't want my mom to leave me alone in the room with this guy.
Look at his eyes.
You know what they say about people whose pupils don't touch the top and bottom of their eyes?
Oh, that's true.
Psychopath.
That thing is gonna beat me to death.
He looks like...
He looks like he's hiding something.
It's the haircut.
It's the bowl cut.
Look at his teeth.
Look at his smile.
Nobody smiles like this.
Anybody who's smiling forever like this is a freak.
If we could change his haircut, what would you say?
We just take him to the barbershop.
We give him a freak bowl cut.
I give him a fade.
I don't wanna look at him anymore.
I'd say pass.
I don't know, it's just too many hands.
I'm curious, so maybe...
I'll smash just for like the one time.
It looks like an udder, dude.
It looks like it's got three nipples.
That's what's freaky about it.
It's got six nipples?
It doesn't have a thumb.
It's six nipples.
Imagine like...
Imagine what?
Nothing.
We should just continue.
Do you wanna suck on these hands?
Yeah, he looks like man gum.
No!
What are they?
Let's just settle this.
What are the hands on Ambipom?
I can't type.
Ambipom.
Wait, I see it now.
I see what she thinks they are.
Utters.
Those are its utters.
I don't think Baller's thinking of the answer.
It says to eat.
It definitely shucks nuts with its two tails.
It rarely uses its arms.
Oh, so they are like hands.
They communicate by connecting their tails to those of others.
Oh my god, they're like Davi!
Yeah, they're like Davis!
They like bind their hands.
They're like... Is that how they bang?
They just touch each other's hands?
Touching tips.
Oh my god, yeah, I can see that.
They touch tips here.
And then they can like self-pleasure by holding their own hand.
Okay.
But now, what if it held my hand?
Are we entering like biological VR chat to like ERP in our minds?
Is that what would happen?
Pass.
Oh my god!
I freaking love Jump Love!
Jump Love's cute, but there's just like pollen and also the fact it's just a round orb.
Pass.
One orb.
What about you, Snuffy?
I'm reading the Pokedex entries on Jump Love.
Are you trying to convince yourself?
I just wanna know.
Maybe there's something there.
It says, blown by seasonal winds, it circles the globe scattering cotton spores as it goes.
Beware of its cotton.
If you accidentally breathe them in, you'll be wracked with coughs and itchiness.
Oh my god.
That's not fun.
Yeah, pass.
It's just allergy season everyday.
Yeah, I'll pass.
I just wanna be its friends.
Pass.
What is this?
It's wheezing, but galar form.
Pass.
You sit on that thing, it'll turn you into a balloon, but like full of gas.
I'll inflate you!
That thing is a bong.
This thing is like the Brat Factory.
No!
Holy...
That came out of your mouth.
Pass.
Missing.
I'll smash my good lord.
Look how bad he is.
Yeah, he looks like a bad boy.
Oh my god.
What was that?
I was just making eye contact with it.
Hey.
Look at those bedroom eyes.
He wants me so bad.
He's like, you mean tonight?
My bed, my room.
Oh my god.
What are even the things on his chest?
What is that?
Ridges for my pleasure.
They're handlebars.
They're for better gripage.
Oh, when this Pokmon sounds as if it's strumming a guitar, it's actually clawing at the protrusions on its chest to generate electricity.
I bet he's got groupies for sure.
Oh, you...
It says as it scatters toxic sweat, it emits electricity.
A melody that sounds like it came from a guitar reverberates through the surrounding area.
Oh, so he plays music in the bedroom.
Yeah, you're gonna be making music for sure.
Oh, he's gonna give you...
Oh, someone's like, he'll give you shocks in bed.
Yeah.
Damn.
Let me put my ponytail up.
He's like, can he play Wonderwall?
I can't.
Not this again.
I'd say...
You know what?
I can see it.
I can see...
I can see the vision.
I'll say smash.
I agree.
Pass.
A creature.
He looks shy and cute though.
He's like, if only you could give me a chance, you know?
I can rock your world.
Just give me a chance.
Wait, why are you smash, Snuffy?
You're giving him a pity smash.
No, it's not a pity smash.
That's my type.
No, the bashful...
Bashful shyness, dude.
So cute, but then I bet like, freak in the bed, you know?
Pass.
Some of y'all in the chat are freaks.
That's like a kitty cat.
Meow.
Do not touch my Volpix.
I will kill you.
Wait, there's the brother.
Snuffy.
The older brother.
What's the difference between him and Bulbasaur?
Bulbasaur is so much nicer than this.
Ivysaur is mean looking.
I feel like he'd give me a poison ivy.
Yeah, he's very snapping turtle-esque.
Exactly.
Pass.
If any of y'all smash, you're going to hell.
Like, what is this body made out of?
What is that?
I always thought it was like, glutinous.
It does look glutinous.
It does.
It looks like a mochi.
Like, he's all squishy and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
I can mold her.
I'mma pass.
Birds kinda scare me most of the time.
I'd say pass, too.
Yeah, pass.
Fidgeot, though?
He's like an asshole, too, right?
There are no new assholes.
I think Ash's Fidgeot was pretty loyal.
Obama Snow.
I really like the way this Pokemon sounds.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
Wait, what does he sound like?
Obama!
Hello, everybody.
He makes a really cool guitar noise.
I don't know why.
I just always thought he sounded so cool.
Yeah, yeah!
What's his Pokedex entry?
He pretends to be a Christmas tree, and then he gives you a little spook.
Wait, really?
No, I made that up.
Honestly, it sounds like Pokemon!
This is the Pokedex entry.
We've done 41 Pokemon already.
Oh my god.
We've sure done them all, right?
Wait.
My fellow, you know this.
Blankets, wide areas in snow by whipping up blizzards.
What?
I wanna hang a star at the top of that Christmas tree.
I'm gonna pass.
I'm just passing.
I wish I could say that I could...
He reminds me of Zoidberg.
It just sounds so ouchy.
Yeah, he looks like Zoidberg-ass.
He even has his claws up, just like him.
Big meat claws.
Oh my god, it's Doki.
Pass.
Oh my god!
I feel like he'll forget where he is, too.
Yeah.
I feel like there's not...
There's like nothing...
And he's gonna get a headache.
What if he's just like, ouch.
Oh my god.
Someone get him some Exeggerant.
The fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
I don't even know.
What is that?
It says he's trapped.
This is literally Vor.
He's like eating himself.
Or 12th length.
How did that happen to him?
Uncut Tango Snake.
When it contracts its body, it's over 220 pounds of sand sprays from its nose.
Whatever runs out of sand, it becomes disheartened.
Okay, that's even worse.
Don't let it run out of sand!
It gets depression.
It's a little sad.
It's like, yeah, but you don't want sand...
Okay, but you don't want sand to get anywhere, though.
That's not fun.
Yeah, that sounds awful.
This unique style of coiling allows it to blast sand out of its sand sack more efficiently.
It just starts blasting sand.
What is that?
What is a sand sack?
Why is he blasting out of a sand sack?
Is that, like, his nose?
What am I thinking?
What does it look like when it's blasting?
Does it just, like, undulate it out?
Show me what it looks like when it's blasting.
It really is pocket sand, dude!
And where was he storing that, Chat?
Where was he storing it?
Oh my God.
That's just...
BPD Pikachu.
Pass.
Yeah, pass.
Come back!
Oh, Greninja?
Come on, Snuffy, that me up.
Oh my God, yes, yes.
That's right.
There's nothing about this Pokmon that hasn't just been, like...
Mhm.
I mean, like...
He uses his tongue as a scarf.
You ever see Ash Greninja, man?
Okay, Ash Greninja...
Yeah, I can... Yeah.
Why is he such a baddie?
He's so fucking sick.
I want this thing to, like...
go out one end and, like, through the mouth.
I get it!
Greninja in the front, Grovyle in the back.
Oh my...
Are they both frogs?
No.
No, it's a reptile.
The other one's a reptile.
This one's a...
A frog is in the...
Wait, is a frog a reptile?
We can make a new species.
Wait.
Greninja.
Let me read Greninja.
This Pokmon is...
4 feet 11.
It weighs 88 pounds.
Skinny King.
It creates throwing stars out of compressed water.
When it spins them and throws them at high speeds, this star can split metal in two.
It appears and vanishes with ninja's grace.
It toys with its enemies using swift movements while slicing them with throwing stars of sharpest water.
Tell me about...
It makes a shuriken out of mucus excreted from its eyes.
No.
Alright.
So it's around its eyes.
Okay.
Extra lube, as they say.
Smash.
That was like self-lubricating.
Oh my god.
Smash.
Doki, you see it, right?
You see the vision, right?
I see it.
I see it, so...
I unfortunately see it, so I'll say smash.
Yes!
Necrozma.
Is that a legendary?
What is that?
It's like an evil legendary in the same game that the first Pokemon, the Solgaleo.
He's like the enemy to those guys.
There's just too many.
It's just too sharp everywhere.
There's too many edges.
In the game, he ends up suckling those Pokemon, the Solgaleo and Moolala and fusing with them into an ultimate fusion form of evil.
Wait, they're evil?
This one is.
He defeats them in battle and takes their power and infuses them and they fuse together into Ultra Necrozma.
Pass.
I don't know.
What can you do?
It says, light is apparently the source of its energy.
It has extraordinarily vicious disposition and is constantly firing off laser beams.
It looks somehow pained as it rages around in search of light.
So he has anger issues.
Oh, I can fix him.
He won't be angry no more when I'm with him.
It needs light to survive and goes on a rampage seeking it out.
Its laser beams will cut anything to pieces.
It is in pain right now.
I'm gonna come up to it and grab it by its face with a single palm, like, babe, this isn't you.
Come on.
Snap out of it.
You're better than this.
Look me in the eyes.
Just focus on me.
Mr. Mime.
Galarian.
I mean, like, Asher's mom likes him.
Yeah, she does.
There's a reason why she never remarried.
I can't.
If you watch the Sun and Moon, like, first episode of the anime, there's, like, a scene where Asher's mom is sitting in a golf cart with Mr. Mime and Mr. Mime's hand is, like, resting on her inner thigh.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've seen it.
I know, like, she takes him everywhere.
Like, it's in every vacation.
Like, she's just...
That's Asher's stepdad.
He knows it.
There's a reason why his dad never came back.
What are the entries for Galarian Mr. Mime?
Yeah, but what's the difference between the normal Mr. Mime and Galarian Mr. Mime?
I guess it'll be...
I don't know how to read.
Hold on, let me see if I can find his...
Pokdex entry.
Do the shoes stay on?
I think that is his flesh.
I think that's part of him.
I don't think they're shoes.
It says, oh my god, the broadness of its hands may be no coincidence.
Many scientists believe its palms became enlarged specifically for pantomiming.
And it's, uh...
It radiates chillness from the bottom of its feet.
It'll spend the whole day tap dancing on a frozen floor.
Just a chill dude.
He's just a chill guy.
Well, I feel like it'd be really annoying, though.
I feel like that'd be really annoying.
I'd be like, get a real job.
I'd be like...
I can't.
Go to college.
Do something with your life.
Yeah, I'd be like...
Get a real job.
Stop being a deadbeat.
So you won't smash him because he doesn't have a real job?
And he pursues an artistic career?
I just...
I don't know.
I just feel like, you know, all he does is tap dancing.
He's so chill.
He probably wards off your hater mentality.
You're having, like, a serious argument over divorce, and he just, like, keeps miming and pretending he's stuck in a box?
He's just tap dancing.
It was like, you don't support me in my career!
I'd be like...
He pretends to walk down the stairs.
I'd be like, what career?!
All you do is dance!
I'm passing.
Pass.
Oh, pass.
That's just a larva.
Oh, yes.
Yeah.
He's too cute.
Oh, my lord.
What is that thing at the bottom?
Is that where it comes out?
It's actually...
He is...
It breathes through a hole in its tail while it burns through an internal fire.
Using its very hot flame-covered tongue, they burn through Durant's steel body and consume their insides.
That's actually what it says.
That's kind of messed up.
That was actually the Pokemon we saw earlier.
It eats that thing alive from the inside, is what it literally just said.
So he'll handle the pest problems.
Yeah, he's an anteater, but he has internal piping that's pumping hot air inside of him.
Yeah, so does he always have to do that?
Like, blow hot air out?
Oh, my god.
Because if he has to do that all the time, I'd say pass.
It just says it breathes through a hole in its tail while it burns with an internal fire.
That's all it says.
He has to always blow that shit out.
Pass.
That's just inconvenient.
What the fuck is that?
Where did this one came out?
This looks like someone's OC gone normal.
What is this?
What is on the top?
Is this a tumor?
Did it, like, stop growing?
There's a tumor on top of the shell.
I think I know it's, like, actual animal.
A turtle?
Yeah, it's based off of a turtle, but it's not a natural turtle.
It's, like, a fish.
Oh, it's the little soft-nosed one.
Oh, that's a long-nosed little thing.
Wait, why is it, like, sex themed, though?
Aphrodite, if she was a weird fish turtle?
That's so true.
Like, why did they, like...
Wait, she has platforms.
Barbie did it.
Oh, my God.
This is its other form?
I don't know why it differs between turning into a soft-nosed turtle fish or, like, a diva.
Some sort of, like, oni.
We did it!
It's a girl!
You don't have to keep...
There's, like, a heart nose.
There's a ear.
There's another nose.
Its Pokdex entry says, When it flies to this land from across the sea, the bitter winter comes to an end.
According to the legend, this Pokmon's lore gives rise to the budding of fresh life.
A different guise from its feminine human form, the cloud that descends upon those who treat any form with disrespect, it means outraffle, ruthless punishment.
What?
I'm scared.
That does not look like a Pokmon anymore.
What is that?
That just looks like those OC creators with those, like, random Pokmon generators where they just smash some random things together and there's, like, that's a Pokmon.
Pass, by the way.
I'm not being a Sandshrew.
Sandshrew is, like, the coolest Pokmon in the world.
He's just gonna roll into a ball because he's scared.
He's, like, Yeah, he's, like...
Don't care.
Defense curl, sand attack.
Whoa, you're just gonna skip him?
We didn't even get to say smash, dude.
For what?
Sandshrew?
What's your problem with Sandshrew, dude?
Why do you wanna smash Sandshrew?
He's just gonna curl up and die!
He's cool.
That's what defense curl and sand attack.
He missed and also defense curl L.
Also for alligator?
Oh my lord.
I feel like he just eats you.
He looks like he could be in the FNAF universe.
Yeah, he could be, like, Foxy from FNAF.
He's a crocodile.
You ever see a crocodile?
They just sit there with their mouths open.
That's kind of just what they'd be doing.
Yeah, and then they eat you.
I'm gonna walk up to, like, in Florida.
I'll be like, this is kind of like FNAF.
This is literally FNAF.
This is the bite of 87 right there.
You're gonna put your head...
This guy looks like Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear, man.
Pass.
I feel like he'd just kill you.
Smash, smash, smash.
Oh my god, smash.
I would smash because, what's his name?
Monty Gator?
He's such a baddie.
Montgomery Gator.
Montgomery Gator?
That's why I see the vision.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, is this, like, from the Esper or something?
Is it the Esper evolution line?
Meowstic.
Pass.
Stares at you.
Esper stare.
I mean, I can tell where you can smash, but, like, pass.
So instead of the orange school rat, it raises its ears and releases enough psychic power to grind a 10 ton truck into dust.
Oh, so she'll kill you before anything happens.
I want her to hypnotize me into, like, falling in love with it.
You know?
So, like, but then will she kill you after?
Like, you're, like, a prey to her?
Or, like, actually?
I don't know.
This article says, females are a bit more selfish and aggressive than males.
If they don't get what they want, they will torment you with their psychic ability.
It will cause you psychic damage if you don't please your female bro.
That's awesome!
It hurt itself in its confusion.
Oh my god, someone's like, oh my god, yonder, right there.
That's crazy.
Yeah, someone's like, yeah, that's a smash.
Yeah, it's like, I can...
They're like, I can fix her.
I can fix her.
I want her to use me.
Pass.
I'll use it to mine Bitcoin.
What is this?
That's a...
a sideguard.
That's Norden Antivirus.
Yeah, that's Norden Antivirus right there.
Yeah.
It says that this thing is a generation of cells.
So it's like 1000 different life forms.
Oh, shit.
It's like DNA?
It wants to die so bad.
The NVIDIA Pokemon.
The NVIDIA.
Pass?
I don't really know what this is.
Like a...
It's like a snake.
Zygarde 100%.
What is that?
Oh, it's a different form.
Yeah, it turns into... Wait, it's kind of a fatty.
Wait, we need to look up Zygarde 100%.
Wait, post a picture in the post a picture in the Discord.
I got you, I got you.
It's like a Digimon.
Wait, he's like NVIDIA Optimus Prime.
Yeah, he's like RTX on.
What's happening to me?
He looks like a transformer.
Yeah, it looks like he's gonna do the transformer sound effect right now.
I was already kind of into it for the worm vibe.
That must feel sensational.
It also has...
Also has what?
Snuffy.
It's another form.
Yeah, what's the other form?
Show me.
Oh, brother.
It resembles some sort of...
Oh my god.
I know people in chat are gonna say smash.
I hate it.
Oh, brother.
She looks like she can step on you.
She looks like she is going to step on you.
I call you like a dirty boy.
She'd make you kiss her heels.
Yeah, I see that.
She wouldn't let you go anywhere above the knee.
Oh my god.
I'm pass.
What?
Pheromosa.
Alright, you know what?
I gotta pull it up.
Let me read this.
The Pokedex entry has to go wild for this.
Pheromosa.
We gotta know the lore.
I wanna know how bad it is.
How much of a baddie she is.
I wanna know what she's gonna do to me.
Oh, they did it dirty with the explanation.
It just says one of the dangerous ultra beasts that has been spotted running across the land at terrific speeds.
Oh, she's fast.
Although it's an alien to this world and a danger here, it's apparently a common organism in the world that it normally lives.
That's all it says.
I feel like we're all just staring at them.
Because you couldn't write what you wanted to, right?
Yeah.
It's like in the leaks, guys.
It's in the Pokemon.
The hidden entry of Pheromosa.
Pheromosa.
It's codename is UB02 Beauty.
Okay.
Ubisoft.
She's literally a beast.
They codenamed the Pokemon Beauty.
Ubi-boobi.
Ubi-doobi.
Scooby-dooby.
I'm a pass.
I don't think I can handle her.
She's 5'11".
55 pounds.
Damn, she's tall.
And skinny.
Pass.
I want to beat that thing with a brick.
What the fuck did he do to you?
Why?
Stupid.
Stupid ass.
What did he do?
Is it because of the way he looks?
I want to hit him with my car as if he's a bugger.
What the?
He's not going to know winning for this, guys.
He looks stupid.
He looks dumb.
He's cheering you on.
He wants you to win.
I don't need your fucking pity vote.
Get out of my face.
He's just a little guy.
He's trying to be a fun guy.
You got this.
You got this, Snuffy.
Snuffy, what are you doing with the car?
Like his rock dusk.
Pass.
Why aren't you guys saying anything?
That's a cool Pokemon.
Smash or pass, guys?
Smash or pass?
What did you say?
I said pass.
Yeah.
I think I hit you off there.
Sorry.
What?
Come on, guys.
What is it?
It's...
I just...
He's orange.
I like the other form.
Oh, yeah?
I would...
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's just...
Alright, Haunter.
I mean, he does get freaky with his tongue.
Does this one do the tongue thing?
Yeah, they all do the tongue thing.
All of them.
They always do the...
Oh, yeah.
Ash's Haunter.
Ash's Haunter was freaky.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Wait.
Get me that Haunter specifically.
Specifically Ash's Haunter.
You're breaking into his PC.
He was up to no good.
He was not satisfied being Ash's Pokemon.
That's for sure.
He wanted to be Sabrina's Pokemon.
God, so do I.
Sabrina and all her Alakazams.
There was something going on.
I get you, Sabrina.
I get you.
I'm passing.
I'm smashing.
Slowking.
He can talk.
Yeah, he can talk.
He really is the one Pokemon that can talk.
Is there any other Pokemon that can talk?
Like Meowth.
Like Telepathy.
Meowth talks.
A lot of the psychic ones can.
Yeah, but Meowth is like the only one in the Meowth family that talks.
Can all Slowkings talk?
Yeah, because they're like really smart.
And they use Telepathy to talk.
Lucario can canonically talk too.
Oh, yeah.
Telepathy.
Meowth learned to speak though.
But that's just in the anime.
Meowth fell in love with another Meowth.
And then he was like, oh, she'll be so impressed if I start talking.
And then he got cooked by a Persian.
Yeah.
I remember this.
Yeah, and then he was like, I'll never fall in love again.
All female Meowths are like bad or some shit.
And then he starts falling in love with other cat Pokemon.
Literally.
He's like, I'm never dating my own kind again.
This one says, This Pokemon is so famed for its intellect that a proverb still persists in some regions.
When in doubt, ask Slowking.
For this one says, It's constantly coming up with new ideas that would change the world.
But as soon as it hits upon a new idea, it forgets it.
Oh, so he's stupid.
And he doesn't...
He's just an ideas man.
He's a genius guy with the intellect.
They're like the memory of a bird.
Sorry, bird joke again.
I already lost it.
Damn it.
He could have found the cure for cancer.
Oh my god.
We have to put him under scrutiny and be like, Slowking, please remember.
The cure is...
What was I saying?
I would pass.
Yeah, he looks like Homer Simpson.
I can't.
You're right.
Oh.
I like his little collar.
He's definitely a freak.
Thinking about how he wanted to start a family that one time.
If I could just take that aspect and forget about everything else, life would be so good.
Just start a hybrid family with Typhlosion.
That guy was twisted, but that just means that Typhlosion's deep down have the nature to want to sit down and have a family.
So find a better one.
He'll take care of you.
He's a family man.
It's like a nature versus nurture thing.
Exactly.
He's different from all the other...
He's different from the Pokemon Legends Typhlosion.
Typhlosion allegations.
He's here to defend himself from the allegations.
Not all Typhlosions.
You're right.
What's his regular Pokdex entry?
What does the world really know about Typhlosion?
The real Typhlosion.
If it's Rage Pete, it becomes so hot.
He got cancelled.
I can't.
How to catch a Typhlosion.
It has a secret devastating move.
It rubs its blazing fur together to cause huge explosions.
Whoa.
What kind of explosion?
He lost his career.
This sucks.
He looks like Bakugo.
Yeah.
No, I see it.
Smash.
Yeah, I see it now.
I'm a smash too.
These guys do goofy.
I want him to sink his little...
I want him to do a little dance.
That's it.
He could cup it.
He could have a touch.
Just like a touch.
Just one touch.
That's it, little guy.
Might I help lift it up?
Oh, do you need a support system?
You need some support right now?
Exactly, exactly.
Pass.
Snuffy?
His name is Driller.
Yes, he has an older brother, Snuffy.
He has an older brother, Snuffy.
Don't have to get the younger one.
My arms are broken from reaching so hard this whole stream.
Pass.
I'm all out.
Why are you looking at me like that?
It's body can dig straight through the ground.
That's crazy.
Why is he looking at us like that?
He has boots on the front, but not boots on the back.
Let's see the fur.
Looking at her.
She hit the ground.
Look at the eyes.
It reminds me of Pepe Le Pew.
I'm gonna pass.
I feel like this one actually looks like a fursona to me.
It looks like a fursona?
It does.
It looks like a fake mon.
Yeah, right?
It just got too big of a head.
And what the fuck is up with the tail?
Is he gonna clean my floors?
Is that a mop?
Yeah, it feels like a mop.
Oh.
You know what?
Smash.
Yeah.
He looks like Tuxedo Mask.
Yeah, right?
I don't think we gotta explain ourselves.
That's obviously a smash right there.
He's just so cool.
Such a cool guy.
Smash.
Pass.
He's just gonna disappear.
He's gonna teleport out.
This guy will ghost you.
Yeah, he would just use teleport.
And he's gone.
I also am genuinely freaked out about their arms.
And their shoulders.
I don't know what that is.
It's very alien-like.
Yeah, it looks like an alien.
I've never been able to catch an Abra in the original first games.
Because I kept fucking teleporting out.
And it pissed me off so bad.
I'm gonna say...
Pass.
I mean, there's a reason why Sabrina had all of them.
That's what I've been saying!
Pass, but I can tell...
I can see it.
Oh, absolutely.
Like, no...
Imagine just being, like, in the pile of that.
I don't need a loophole for this spaghetti.
That's so hot.
I need me a weird tentacle monster.
I'm passing, but I can see the vision.
Just, not for me.
It's absolutely filled with that thing.
My dreams would come true.
Pass.
What the fuck do I do with this?
What is it?
It's like a ninja, I guess?
A ninja bug?
Oh, is it like Ninjask or whatever?
Yeah, it's two feet tall.
It's 55 pounds.
He's two feet tall?!
He looks so...
He looks like a short king.
Dumbass does not make sense.
I hate it.
Having removed its heavy shell becomes very light and can fight with ninja-like movements.
When its body dries out it weakens.
It wraps a membrane around itself for protection.
Wait.
Apparently, it's a ninja slug.
A ninja slug?
Where's the slug?
It's, like, inside.
Like, this is the snail.
The membrane must be the ninja covering thing.
Yeah.
You can see, like, the snail shell right here.
I think.
And then...
Yeah, that part is the shell.
And then he's in here.
Pass.
It's confusing.
I hate it.
Pass.
Oh my God, he's...
He's what?
Pass.
He's so cute.
I would, like, sleep on top of it.
I won't do anything to it, but I'll sleep on top of it.
He's just here.
He's a comfy little guy.
Pass.
I do love Marshtomp, though.
He's just a fun guy.
A smash of whimsy and joy?
Yeah, I don't wanna...
Are you gonna corrupt Marsht...
You're gonna corrupt him?
No, Marshtomp would, like, marry me first.
And then...
have children.
But then he'll lose his whimsy.
Innocence.
I would meet Marshtomp in college.
And we'd, like, be in the same book club or something.
You're, like, coming up with this whole scenario of how you guys meet.
And then we'd, like, talk at the library and then his little fins would, like, slightly brush against my, like, pinky.
And then he'd be like, sorry.
Then he evolves into Swampert when you guys settle down.
Yeah, and then my room smells like a swamp.
My God!
Pass.
Okay.
I think he's just...
I feel like he'll not be there the next day.
I'm in love with an emo girl.
He's like an e-boy.
This guy would take a photo of himself being, like, emo and be like, I was thinking of you today.
What are those cams called?
Those TikTok cams for e-boys?
What are they called?
Fan cams?
Yeah, it looks like he makes a fan cam of himself.
And then, like, shows his abs like, hey girl, you ever seen this?
Pass.
Wow.
I don't like his vibes.
I don't like his vibes either.
I don't think he'll call the next day.
He's a fuckboy.
Yeah, he is.
He is a fuckboy.
He definitely...
He would probably... He would call.
He would be desperate.
Yeah, he would be super desperate and cling to you and be super talkative.
Oh, thirst traps!
That's what I'm talking about.
He makes those thirst traps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, he 100% makes thirst traps.
There's no...
I was just thinking of you tonight, babe.
And he texts that to, like, six other girls.
And then everyone finds out.
Sorry, lol.
Sorry, that's the accident.
Pass, pass.
Pass.
Oh, that's the pre-evolution of that thing that alien mind control.
Yeah, yeah.
Really?
You raise it and then the mind controls you later.
The way you evolve him is when you evolve him, you have to flip your Nintendo DS upside down.
Wait, what?
Oh, because, like...
Yeah, I remember that.
Yeah, because, like, his hair becomes... That's, like, his hair later.
Yeah, he, like, flips upside down.
Yeah, yeah.
So that's how you evolve him.
I see it.
But you literally would have to flip your DS.
It knew.
It was cute.
I wonder, like, how you evolve it now.
No, because you can't...
Chat says you can do it with your switch skill.
Oh, okay.
I guess because you're portable and you need to flip it.
Oh, that's smart.
Pass.
Oh.
Not that one.
The other one.
This one's a saw blade.
No, not this one.
Cut your fucking innards in half or, like, shreds.
Pass.
I'd like to keep my intestines, please.
Oh, God.
I don't like it.
Not...
He swims up.
This guy...
Get a load of this guy, alright?
Pass.
He looks like a dreepy... He looks like one of those, like, no thoughts dogs.
He looks like...
He looks like he runs into walls on accident.
Yeah, he looks like he's chasing his tail, too, but he just doesn't stop.
And you're like, is he okay?
Century says it's so weak that a mere child can fight it.
Wait, what?
Fucking child.
It's like...
It's like there's, like, those, like...
Why would that kid is beating up this defenseless little guy, dude?
You know, like, how... Have you ever read that article where a daycare got shut down because they were running a secret underground, like, baby ring?
Oh, yeah!
They were doing TikToks, weren't they?
Or something?
I feel like they were... Yeah.
Something crazy like that.
A toddler fight club?
Yeah, there was a toddler fight club, and a daycare got shut down because people found out it was, like, an underground fight club for children.
And then I could see that.
You put a dreepy there and a child, and you were like, who would win, guys?
Next week, my child's gonna fight this iggly bum.
What the...
Child or Pokemon?
G-G-G-Gum versus coughing baby.
We do not talk about the toddler fight club.
Yeah, and then they found out because it got, like, uploaded on TikTok or some shit.
Yeah, yeah.
That's so funny.
They had, like, an account, and I think it was something like people saw in the background or something, and they got investigated, and it was, like, super crazy.
It's so crazy.
Surely it wasn't real fights.
I think it was a fight club.
It was...
I think it was because, like, people would report that their kid would come back, like, with bruises and scars.
Yeah, because they're like...
And then they're like, oh, your child just fell down, you know?
Like, they just fell down a couple of stairs type deal.
I'm just surprised they got away for so long.
Well, to be fair, daycares are incredibly hard to, like...
Like, get in.
They're desperate.
Alright, Molly Mega.
Molly?
Oh, sorry.
How do you pronounce it?
Mawile?
Mawile.
I don't know why, she's so cute.
Like, I guess, like...
Rattysundere Mawile.
No, she'd be kinda kudere.
I feel like she'd be...
What does kudere mean?
Yeah, what is kudere?
Like, uh...
Like, kinda...
Cool with it?
I don't know how to...
She's like Sabrina.
She does sorta look like Sabrina.
It says, Don't be taken by this Pokemon's cute face.
It's very dangerous.
Mawile fools the foe into letting its guard down, then chomps down with its massive jaws.
The steel jaws are really horns that have been transformed.
Dude, I wanna be Brock with his victory bell.
I feel like Brock would just be, like, even better.
Is that Brock, or was that...
What was his name?
Oh, James!
James!
Oh yeah, James is the one with the victory bell.
Yeah, that would have woken something in me for sure.
Victory bell?
You wanna get forged by a victory bell?
Yeah, his victory bell would just start...
I'm just wondering, like, when you start you get, like, semi-digested, you know?
By the...
I guess...
You just wanna get digested a little bit, you know?
That's how she shows her love to me.
It's like, digesting the clothes off my body.
It's like a Komodo dragon.
Alright, I can see the vision.
I'll say smash.
Pass.
I'll say pass.
Unless you wanna do a wax play.
I mean, he's a portable wax play.
I say pass.
I'ma keep it at that.
What?
That's a candle.
That's a cat.
Yeah, there's nothing wrong with letting your Pokmon sit on you.
I can't.
Pass.
That's just a problem in bed.
If, like, Jumpluff was, like...
If Jumpluff was a problem, this one's just a disaster.
Yeah, yeah.
Pass.
Turn your body into a chia pet.
Moss growing on your butt or something.
Pass.
Actually, that thing was a foot tall.
I didn't even know.
I thought that was, like, a tinier one.
Cleffa?
Nah, this thing is...
Pass.
I turn him into a bong.
What do you do?
How?
What is the correlation anymore?
It's lava!
I can't even...
It doesn't even have, like, a hole or anything.
At least the rock I could, like, wedge it between and get some, like, severe burns.
But this is, like... If I even touch it, I'm just melting.
At least...
She makes no sense.
It's a vibe sort of thing.
Like, there's no rocks for her to do it.
Yeah, yeah.
This is just...
This is just lava.
It's like wanting to fuck my, like, kitchen sink.
Pass.
It's a poodle.
This thing is a freak and belongs to somebody freakier.
Dude.
I know... You know how, like, golden doodles and... Sometimes they have, like, human-esque eyes.
They look like a human trapped inside of a dog.
The worst part is, is, like, even though the eyes look like that, it's because I feel like they make eye contact with you.
They don't look anywhere else.
They just stare at you just like that.
And it's just like...
Freak dogs.
Golden doodles, like, bark at them because I'm like, I know what you are.
I know.
Pass.
You're a human so trapped in that dog.
I know it.
You've committed some sin to be here.
Pass.
It looks kind of like a sonic person.
I don't know why.
He looks like a sonic ghost, like a sonic villain.
Or, like...
Algium.
Or, like... Yeah, he just looks like someone that belongs in Sonic.
Pass.
This thing says it uses psychic power to squeeze its opponent's brain causing unendurable headaches.
That's just horrific.
Squeezing the brain.
Rumors of its origin are linked to a UFO crash site in the desert 50 years ago.
What?
I didn't even know that.
This thing can squeeze your brain and it came from a UFO.
Why do we let this on Earth just, like, wander around?
Why does the government not take him away?
Why are we letting him free from the world?
Let's let this thing integrate with our other species.
It's the natural order of Pokemon.
Pokemon have no rights to lock him up.
The Roswell Pokemon.
Oh my God.
That was Glorp.
Glorp.
Eggly Glorp.
Seadra.
Okay, I can see how people would smash Seadra.
Yeah, same.
I didn't see it, but I pass.
Yeah.
Pass.
It says touching the back fin causes numbness.
It hooks its tail to coral.
Kind of intriguing.
Alright, pass.
Orbeetle.
Looks like a Bakugan.
Oh, it does!
Yeah!
Looks like a Bakugan.
Yeah, that's a pass.
Holy Big Mac!
Dude, it says that's its brain on the Pokedex.
What?
This thing?
I don't like that at all!
I'm just gonna grip the brain?
Yeah.
Pass.
Like, the fin would be in the way here.
You look so gentlemanly, though.
Oh my God, she's one of those...
Pass.
He would call me Ojo-sama.
Ojo-sama?
He does!
Look at his chest.
He's got like a maid pattern.
He's like a butler.
He's an empress.
Yeah, he is like a butler.
He can carry you anywhere.
He'd be like, my lady.
Butler, quick!
Make me a hot chocolate.
Yes, Ojo-sama.
He's so nice.
Someone was like, I named him Sebastian.
Twirling my hair.
Fin for spanking.
What?
Yeah.
Whoa.
I'm passing.
Wow.
He's such a good pick, too.
Husbando material.
Treats you so well.
He can't even bend his arms.
Look at him.
No, he can.
Look at that.
It's just a flat surface.
It's like a table.
He doesn't need to.
He's got fingers, see?
And he can do that.
He can do anything you would want him to do.
Try.
For you.
He'll try his best.
I want him to...
Be quiet.
I have bad feelings towards Drowsy.
I...
Yeah, me too.
I saw the leaks.
I saw...
I have negative feelings towards Drowsy.
I feel like...
Yeah...
Pass.
I don't like it.
Explode.
Pass.
I feel like...
I mean, he has a lot of holes.
Fellas...
Fellas, would you smash?
He's extra loud.
What are you saying, though?
Are you really suggesting that people wanna, like, stick a dick in his, like, knee hole?
Yeah, like, all the...
No, not just the knee.
There's holes everywhere.
There's one, two...
He could be an ocarina.
An ocarina?
Do you think if you put your...
You put your dingle dongle into one hole and you start thrusting, it's gonna make, like, a sound out of the others?
Yeah!
No, it's gonna be like...
Just play.
Oh, my God.
You can fuck his brains.
You can fuck his brains out.
My thought is that I can fuck his brains out.
That is...
No!
I'm gonna use him as a JBL speaker and play Fetty Wap.
Pass.
Oh, pass.
I can see him in the corner, though.
One of my most hated Pokemon.
Bucky's beaver.
I can see you put him in the corner.
He's a watchdog.
Bussy's beaver.
Pass.
It's just a fish.
I will now pleasure myself with this fish.
Yes.
Just exactly.
There's something I specifically think of every time I see this.
And yes, yes, it's always been a dream of mine.
I don't care if I would die.
Wait, isn't he, like, electric Pokemon, too?
No, he's an earth type.
He's a mudfish.
Wait, how do you know so much about Barboach?
Because I love Barboach.
I unironically love Barboach.
He's one of my favorite Pokemon.
When I was a little kid, I probably had 200 Barboach cards.
And most of them were exactly the same card from the same set.
He's so cute.
He is weird.
He's so cute that you want him in you?
Yes.
You ever see that one eel video, Doki?
What?
Oh.
What video?
It shouldn't be mentioned, actually.
So, if you haven't seen it...
You know...
I don't even know.
What do you mean by that?
My chat's like, do not engage.
I just inulted my brain forever.
If you know, you know.
I know, I know.
Alright, alright.
Asumaru.
Pass.
That's the Easter Bunny.
I'm like...
Pass.
He's just here to have a good time.
I wanna go... I wanna like, bait with it.
Like, make a cupcake.
Pass.
Doki.
That's wrong.
Doki's baby pictures.
This was before you grew your first head feathers.
Before I got my head feathers.
Can you imagine?
Baby Doki, but without the feathers.
Guys, please.
Doki community, please draw a naked baby.
Baby Doki.
I can't wear clothes.
What do you mean by baby?
As a bird?
I think as a baby bird.
Officer.
I didn't mean it like that.
Like a chicken.
Like a baby chick.
I need some bathroom after that.
I'll be right back.
I'm crying.
Why?
I'm squirming.
I'm writhing like...
Like a snail you just sprayed salt on.
My bee.
Blending.
Poipole.
Very nice.
This definitely doesn't look just like an enema.
Poipole.
The Poipole.
It looks like it would be...
A little trickster.
And it would install...
Really fricked up viruses on your computer.
And it would...
Find joy in that.
He would scam me on Gaia Online.
Yeah!
That's true.
Wait, this thing has like no...
It says...
This Ultra Beast is well enough liked to be chosen as a first partner in its own world.
Oh, it's like a...
It's like a Squirtle in its own world.
It's like a starter Pokemon in an alternate world.
That's kind of cute, actually.
That is cute.
It got a big head.
Looks like a...
Like a cyber rotisserie chicken.
It cackles wildly as it sprays opponents with the poison needles on its head.
Those are needles?
Yeah, I guess it's...
It belongs to Ash.
Really?
I didn't know Ash had an Ultra Beast.
I've never seen this thing, really.
In media or a game.
It becomes a syringe dragon.
Wait, now I want to see its...
Oh my god.
What is that?
That's definitely an enema.
This is just the enema Pokemon.
No!
It's about to give me the COVID vaccine.
I hate it!
It was so cute!
It has so much potential to be like a Curly or something.
Wait, what are you guys talking about?
Back, by the way.
Dude, look up this Pokemon's evolution.
Please, right now.
Yes, look up Poipole Evolution.
Okay, wait, give me the picture.
It's in the Discord.
Naganadel, I think is its name.
Yeah, let me post the picture for you.
It looks like this.
What the fuck!
That's what I've been saying!
Maybe you can stick something in.
Oh my god!
It's a literal douche!
I can't!
That's what I'm saying.
Why is it a douche?
Oh my god!
Why is it shaped like that?
Why is it?
Oh my god!
I can't.
I'm ill.
I'm passing.
That's just an anchor.
I would grind against that thing, though.
No!
Why?
I mean, I can see like...
Yeah, I can see you guys.
That shit got quite the badussy.
The turkey baster.
I think like...
The ghost is this one.
The seaweed is the ghost part.
He just like grabs on to like...
Random stuff?
Yeah, apparently.
I remember it's the seaweed that's the actual part of him.
I wanna know the lore now.
I love ghost Pokemon lore.
Oh my god, what is this?
Swinging its massive anchor, it can KO Wailord in a single blow.
It can KO Wailord?
It's like a brain damage.
It just crushes the skull in.
Dude, that's crazy.
It says it wraps its prey in green seaweed and sucks away their vitality.
It only likes to go after big prey like Wailord.
Oh, goodbye, Bao.
It specifically is a Wailord prey.
What the heck?
Oh my god, it just says, fuck you, Wailord.
I'm passing.
It one shots me.
Get this guy away from me.
I want him to hold me in his little cape arms and cuddle me.
He looks like a gentleman.
He looks like a perfect gentleman.
He's gonna clean your hair like a bird.
Oh my god, like preen you and everything?
He's gonna...
You guys are like, hold on.
It's so crazy.
I know.
And he has bird abs too, right here.
Oh my god, a bird abs.
That's crazy.
They look like abs, but then when you touch them, they're probably so soft.
They're soft.
Oh my god.
He's the perfect man.
How tall is he?
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Is this a Dew-Eye?
Yeah, this is a Dew-Eye.
He's five feet.
He is perfect.
Alright, smash.
Dash me, man.
Pass.
Don't even...
Wait.
He can hold you.
This is literally like a human, practically.
He kinda looks like Barra Art, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, I see that.
Barra Yaoiya's art.
Yeah.
I feel like...
There's like a specific artist...
that's very famous...
for Barra Art.
What's his name?
He looks like he'd be illustrated by him.
He looks like he's like an after school summoner's character.
I'd still smash them.
I feel like...
I'd pass.
I feel like he'd just use me as a beard.
That's crazy.
Wow.
Ooh.
Still pass.
My entire chat is chanting...
One pump chump.
One pump chump!
Because it says single strike.
That's wild.
He's just...
Bro, he's just not ready for it.
It's too much.
It's just too much for him.
Strike of his fist.
Instakill.
Up your ass.
Oh, we're at 95 now, guys.
You guys wanna call it when we hit 100?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Our last 5, guys.
Last 5.
Pass.
I know like this...
The nails are supposed to be poisonous too.
So it's like, he can't grip you...
because he's gonna fucking poison you.
No matter what.
At night, you hear the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have like a fucking antidote.
So you can't even like...
So like, he licks you and then you get poison.
It just says the poison is in its knuckle claws...
that secrete toxin...
and it's pumped from the sack.
So I don't think...
I think only the claws have the sack.
So like, you have to bandage it up.
Go, yo, yo, yo, yo.
I'm gonna pass.
It's like a little stress ball.
Ew, it's probably like...
I would be scared I'd like pop it.
Do you guys remember Brock's...
crow gunk?
And he would constantly like...
iron fist his ass whenever like...
Officer Jenny appeared?
Oh yeah.
Kick him in the balls.
Yeah, that was so funny.
Pass.
Poison stored in the sack, yeah.
Oh hey, that's your favorite Pokemon.
Duffy.
But like, bigger.
This doesn't look as fun to go up the ass anymore.
There's no appeal whatsoever now.
Skip, pass.
But he has the Hulk fist.
Wait, but he has the Hulk fist though.
Nah.
Your favorite.
Yeah, what's the difference between these?
He looks so much scarier.
He's angry just like Hulk.
Darmanitan.
So you're willing to put a...
Hulk fist on top of a...
Rhyhorn.
He looks like a freak.
He's heavy breathing.
He's like...
That's a freak.
It says it's internal fire...
burns at 2500 degrees...
Fahrenheit, which is actually...
more.
That's hotter than the...
flame in coal piles.
Making it enough power...
that it can destroy a dump truck...
with one punch.
It just deflates your ass.
It just starts deflating.
One punch.
Sudowoodo.
I love Brock's Sudowoodo.
He wouldn't want...
He would take active damage.
If like...
Yeah, I feel like he's...
He always gets hurt, right?
He's like...
weak as hell in the end.
Yeah, he's like a...
rock type.
Yeah, he's a rock type, but he's like weak.
He's a weak rock type.
He's got bad stats.
I feel like if like...
you do like one thing to him, he'll like...
in critical care, he'd be like 1 HP.
You'd have to take him to...
Sudowoodo.
He'd be scared of you.
He like runs from people.
Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like if I get robbed, I'd die.
He'll just run away.
This has got to be the worst Pokemon.
Yeah, it has the ability...
He's afraid of a watering can.
Is this anybody's favorite?
I've never heard anybody say Sudowoodo is their favorite.
And they say somebody's, you know, there's a Pokemon for everybody, right?
Yeah, but he's so silly.
I don't...
Really?
He runs when it rains.
He just kind of looks uncomfortable.
I don't like his spots, too.
He looks sick.
He's so cute.
I don't believe that person.
He has a weakness to water.
There's no...
He's so weak to water.
What do we do?
Anyone into piss play?
We can't do anything with him.
He's...
He'll die.
He'll actually die.
No, do not the Sudowoodo.
Okay, pass.
I mean, like, what do I...
It's just Ditto with a metal head.
It's like a Ditto, but like...
Mercury.
He's not even an inch in height, also.
But he weighs 17 pounds, despite being not even an inch tall.
Oh, he's a tungsten cube.
It says it melts particles of iron and other metals found in the subsoil, so it can absorb them into its body of molten steel.
No, please don't call him the car!
Imagine that, dude.
Putting your thingy in there, and then, like, it's like jello.
Oh, it's like weighing you down.
It starts like...
Oh, you flex it.
You can make it stronger.
It's like a weight, you know?
It's like one...
You know?
Because, like, I can move that.
But it's like one, two...
It's draining!
What is bro training for?
What would you train?
I can't...
That is some bonky shit.
I can't.
What are the remaining Pokmon we're getting?
My bro on the...
My bro's on the right nostril, and I'm on the left nostril.
And there's a third one, too, on the back.
We can have the bro on top, right here.
On top of it, right there.
I'm just gonna be fucking, like, umbrella-ing on that thing.
Spinning around.
So, you know how, like, there's, like, the Eiffel Tower?
There's one on top here, you lie on top here, and then one here, and the other here.
We are never joining the Pokmon League.
You know what we said about how, like, halfway through this, you would be...
I feel like now you're truly thinking with gusto.
We're trying to think how it works.
How would it work?
Eiffel Tower and Hippopotas.
I'm so proud!
Still pass, though.
Still pass.
I try to think, I try to envision it.
Oh my god!
We are not ending on Vanilluxe.
We are not ending on this guy.
Wow!
If you flip it over, if you flip it over, and then, like, stick it on the floor...
Dude, I gotta look up the pose again.
This one I'm so curious about as well.
Let me consult the books.
Hold on.
Someone said the left one looks freaky.
Oh my god, wait!
You guys, I'm gonna post something.
It's gonna be...
I'm gonna spoiler it, though, because there's some little dirty...
Just, like, warning.
Oh my god, dude!
Oh my god!
Where did you find such a little piece of art?
I mean, it does look like two boobs right there.
So, like, guys, would you smash if, like...
The two...
So, it's like, you know, it looks like a boob right there.
Would you smash?
I'm gonna show you the Tommy's ice cream coins.
I'm gonna show you the top one.
The last of one, master.
The left one truly was the freaky one.
Oh, that's not with cream at the top.
No.
Sir, this is a... this is a Dairy Queen.
Get out of the ice cream cake, sir.
Get out of the ice cream cake section.
Okay, I'm gonna do another one.
We are not ending up in the Lux.
Here we go.
A trad wife.
Yeah, she looks like a traditional wife for you.
Mega.
She, like, is...
She looks like she'll bake for you.
She's like a maid.
She's the new...
Yeah, she's the new, like, uh, chancy at the... what are they called?
Yeah, she looks like she'll take care of you and she'll let you, like, um, let you put your head on her laps.
She's like the Chobits Pokmon.
Yeah.
This Pokmon has a kind heart.
By touching with its feelers, Ardino can gauge other creatures' feelings and physical conditions.
She will always know what's on her mind.
Oh my gosh, she'll always be there for you.
She's a mommy.
Marriage.
She'll be like, she's marriage material.
I'd smash.
Yes.
Who said nurse play?
I'm gonna cry.
Smash and marriage.
Smash and marriage right there.
She'll take care of me.
I'll show her a place to sleep.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, how about we end it on Blastoise Gigantamax?
That's a canon every hole.
He looks bad at Big Man Blastoise.
Big Man Blastoise.
Isn't Gigantamax literally as tall as a building?
Yeah.
I feel like if you just sit on one of the canons, you'd get like, water gunned.
Hydro pump.
Just hydro pump it.
Hell yeah.
I'd spit on one of his freaking claws.
Wow.
Like a freaking...
What are those things called?
A fidget spinner, dude.
I'd let him fidget spinner me.
You'd just fidget spin you.
Like the water fidget spin.
Wow.
I don't know what it is, but I just really like Blastoise.
I think he exudes...
Look at this guy.
He's freaking aura farming.
Look at him.
It's so true.
Oh, that's true.
The way he looks at you.
I love it.
Yeah, he's such a badass.
Sorry, Charizard.
I'm with a badder boy now.
I get it.
No, I get it.
I see...
I see her vision.
I see it.
I'm gonna look up Blastoise hentai and see what happens.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
What happened?
You're just gonna stop it there?
No!
What's happening?
This was everything I...
What do you mean this was everything?
This was the third cannon.
This was the third fucking cannon.
All right.
Share it in Discord.
I'm too scared.
I'm too scared to look it up.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't want it.
This one's my favorite.
Which one?
Wait, what do you mean which one?
Is there more than one?
There's a lot.
There's that one.
What happened to his shell in all of these situations?
What the fuck?
Where did his shell go?
Why is he naked?
Dude, that's literally like the sonic arc.
Why is this just abhorrentance?
Why is it just...
Oh my god, okay.
The third cannon was pretty funny.
The third cannon is pretty good.
These are crazy.
These are just...
Oh my god.
I get the first one.
He's just...
Is this a donkey version?
Why does he just take...
He takes off his shell while he showers?
Wait, I could probably show this to chat.
Oh my god, it's the same...
Oh my god.
He looks more like a dodogama without his shell.
From Monster Hunter.
He looks so cute.
Can I even...
I feel like the shell is part of the hotness for me.
I need it.
The shell?
Because that's where all the cannons are.
He's just cannonless.
He's actually naked.
He's naked.
This is awesome.
Guys, I can't show it on chat.
I'm sorry, guys.
It's a naked Blastoise.
I can't.
It's a naked...
He doesn't even have a shell, guys.
Guys, he doesn't even have a shell on.
Guys, I can't.
He took it off just for you tonight.
Keep the shell on.
I have tears welling up in my eyes.
He doesn't love me if he takes off his shell.
He's an old boy, you know?
I feel like he's built to be Barra, though.
Look at him.
His face alone screams Barra.
That's not fair.
He's just a turtle.
He has to have a big shell.
Let me remind you that this is just what he is.
This is screaming Barra, really?
Look at his regular, pure little face.
Yeah, but Bowser is filled with Barra art of him.
I feel like Bowser is like...
He's like...
He wants a wife, you know?
Bowser is seeking love, first of all.
So he's like...
What do they call him?
A bachelor?
Which already kind of makes him appealing.
Yeah, he's a Delph.
He's basically a Delph right there.
What?
He has like...
10 kids.
Oh my god!
I am definitely not showing that.
Bow showed us a picture.
I'll describe it, guys.
So you can have it mentally in your head.
Because I had to look at it.
Bow sent us a picture of a...
Of a half-naked Blastoise.
Without a shell on.
And he's rubbing his nipples.
Where is he rubbing his nipples?
I guess it kind of looks like...
He's ripping his shirt again.
He's ripping his shirt open.
And was like...
You want to rub these nipples?
And then...
She sent us another picture.
Of the same Blastoise.
And you can...
He's wearing...
Someone said he was rubbing his nipples.
I thought... He kind of looks like he's doing that again.
And he's like...
Yeah, and then he's also half-naked.
And then he's in tighty-whities.
And you can clearly see...
His third cannon.
Ready to...
To fire.
This is nothing but a waste lot.
I know!
Put in a waste lot.
I had a feeling someone would do this.
Okay.
I just found the art, okay?
Anyway, guys.
That was fun.
That was a great experience.
I had a...
I need to go take a shower.
Cleanse the filth off of us.
Cleanse the filth.
I gotta...
Maybe I should go to confessional after.
Yeah.
I'll see you all on Sunday.
I need to repent.
I need to repent for my sins.
I should really use...
Some holy water today.
Anyway, guys.
Well, thank you...
Bow and Snuffy...
For joining me today...
On this wonderful adventure.
I saw a lot...
Of the visions you guys painted for me.
The imagery...
That was sent to me.
Either mentally...
Or actual pictures...
I looked at.
The different...
Possibilities.
I'm just saying...
A bunch of rocks and some coal...
Have never gotten before.
It makes no sense.
Don't you guys...
Want to warm up your insides...
Like Snuffy does?
It's like sitting by the fire...
Except you're in the fire pit.
Third degree burns.
Wow.
I wonder what it's like to get...
Third degree burns inside.
Inside your body.
Wow.
It was very educational.
Thank you, girls.
I enjoyed the experience.
Thank you for joining.
Can't wait to start our Pokemon journey.
Spoiler, we've been banned from every region.
We're not allowed near any Pokemon Center.
Within 10 meters of a Pokemon Center.
We are...
We are the problem...
That Team Plasma tried...
To warn you about.
We have our own level of...
Wanted by the...
Pokemon individual of the game.
We have our own evil org.
Anyway, are you...
Are you going to keep streaming, Bell?
Nah, I'm going to raid.
You're going to call here?
Me too.
I'm going to go talk to my chat.
Real quick.
Thank you, girls, for joining.
I had a great time with you guys.
Thank you.
Very educational.
I'll have this Discord group chat.
I can look back into this group chat...
With fond memories.
Don't do that.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye-bye.
Bye, guys.
Take care.
Oh my god.
That was...
What a wild ride.
I was not expecting...
How this stream was going to turn out.
I went in like...
I didn't know what degree of...
Degeneracy we were going to get into.
Because I knew...
Inviting Bao and Snuffy...
Was going to open...
A whole new layer.
On this channel.
I was ready for it.
I was like...
No restrictions.
No barriers.
Let's go all in.
Let's go.
Let's just...
It was rather tame.
Snuffy literally said...
She was going to stick...
Electrodes up her ass.
Voltorb up her ass.
And then I suggested...
Give them all EXP share.
So then...
When you level one of them up...
You can evolve them.
You think that's tame?
That was freaking freaky.
That's vanilla.
Yeah, that's pretty tame.
You don't understand, Doki.
It could have been much worse.
For me, that opened...
A whole other level for me.
I don't think I've gone that beyond...
Before they held back.
Anyway...
I'm going to...
I hope you guys...
Had a...
Great time today.
I had a great time with the girls.
It was definitely...
I've never done a Smasher Pass before.
This was a charity...
Reward.
This was a charity goal.
For last year's charity stream.
Where I said if we reach the amount...
We'll do a Pokemon Smasher Pass.
So I hope you guys enjoyed the stream.
We went through...
Layers that we haven't...
Went through before.
Especially for me.
Before I go...
I do want to show...
One thing before I go.
For those who don't know...
These plushies are going to be...
Have one day left...
To pre-order.
So after 24 hours...
These will be gone forever.
So make sure...
To grab your plushies before it's gone.
We have 24 hours left.
So yes.
Find my merch.
It's a great way to support me.
And also you get your very own Doki merch.
That's the last thing I'm going to show today.
Hey guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
To get that blood flowing.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.